And totally five,
four,
three,
two,
one that Jeremy motherfucking and Steve.
What's up buddy?
Good to see you,
man.
Yeah,
you too,
man.
Thanks for having me back.
My pleasure.
Brother was cracking skulls and skulls
or you're coming off of a fucking
gigantic victory man all over.
Hanan Barao who was just a little while
ago,
consensus.
Top three pound for pound fighter in the
world.
Man.
That was a big victory.
Yeah.
I think there's a before a Usada,
you know?
Yeah.
I feel like it's on level playing fields
and you kind of wonder who would be
champions for people who don't know what
we're talking about.
You sought out the US antidoping agency
was hired by the UFC to clean up the
sport.
And God damn bodies are dropping massive
massive bodies dropping.
I watched the documentary on uh,
uh,
the cyclist,
lance,
Lance Armstrong,
and just watch how that guy just lied
and manipulated his way and you know,
people were just calling the smoke and
long time before that.
And then,
uh,
you know,
here comes a Wicki.
It was a pretty scary dude if you ever
met him.
Night,
night and Nice is a very nice guy.
Awesome dude.
But you know,
he means business man.
He doesn't try to catch the cheaters
and,
and uh,
I'm,
I'm actually happy because I've always
taken pride in being a natural man and
if I feel like you need to start pumping
steroids,
maybe it's time for you to get out,
you know.
But,
uh,
I,
I love it.
Well,
Lance Armstrong's defense,
that entire sport was dirty.
That's a different sport because if you
like when it's really crazy because all
the years he won,
they like took his titles away,
right?
Yeah.
And while he still has,
he's been on the podcast,
I talked to him.
He's a good dude,
man.
He's in a bad.
He was in a bad spot.
If they took his title away and they
gave it to the next person that didn't
test positive,
it'd be 18th place.
That's how dirty that supportive.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Dirty,
dirty,
dirty sport.
Yeah.
And I was asking him,
I was like,
well,
what,
you know,
he's,
he doesn't know what they're doing
today,
but I'm like,
well how are they doing it today if
they're still breaking records?
He's like,
we'll find out one day,
we'll find out eventually one day that
they're going to figure out what the
fuck these people are doing.
But Novitsky was explaining all the
weird little loopholes that people are
finding like testosterone
supplementation that comes from animals
instead of from wild yams.
Did you know that?
That's how they catch him.
Yeah.
No,
I've,
I've heard of people doing stuff like
that.
But I mean that just seems insane.
I mean,
last time we're going to show you were
talking about how somebody was pulling
out their blood and refrigerating it and
yeah,
it was at doping basically epo.
That's.
Well that's,
that is still going on.
That's definitely still going on.
And apparently the way they're supposed
to be able to test that.
Like you're not supposed to use an IV,
right?
Yup.
And the reason why you're not supposed
to use an ivs that somehow or another
through intravenous fluids,
you can mask the effects of doping.
So they also have been able to detect
minuscule,
um,
plastic particles from the tubes that
they use to put ivy fluids back into
your body.
They've been able to detect those
apparently,
but no one's ever been caught for that.
So that's what they would do.
They would,
they would either use a blood that's
your own blood or in Lance Armstrong's
case,
a lot of the people that were taking
epo,
which makes your body produce more
blood.
But I think guys to this day are
probably still putting blood back into
their body.
That's insane.
Gives you an advantage,
you know,
and it's kind of scary,
you know what I mean?
This drastic way.
And then you're pulling blood and then
you know,
with everything going on.
Well I know a dude that walked into a
fighters' dressing room,
I'm not dressing room,
hotel room and they had bags of blood in
the hotel room.
They pulled his blood out so he could
make weight.
Yeah.
You were telling me that last time.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
that's freaky.
That's freaky.
Yeah,
because that's not sanitary.
You're not in the hospital.
You're in some hotel room where people
had been farting and shooting loads all
over the place.
It goes to shit all over the wall.
You're just gonna take your blood out
and that environment,
like that's creepy man.
That was like you said,
that was like a long time ago too.
Yeah,
that was a long time ago.
Well,
people have been.
They've been definitely cheating
forever,
but now we're seeing the effects of it.
Like people's physiques are changing.
The way they fight is changing the way
they look there.
Joel.
Yeah.
Everything about them.
Their attitude,
like their confidence,
like some of these guys,
like they're becoming different human
beings.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I the level playing field,
people were getting knocked out,
you know,
their,
their bodies are changing and they're.
And they're seeing that their fight
style is guys,
we're going undefeated and just all
these rampages you're like,
man,
he must be in great shape.
He's just killing it in the fifth round
and now he can't get past round one,
two,
you know,
and you're just like,
wow.
Yeah.
And the technique is king,
right?
Technique and training and heart and
courage and cardio and cardio.
Yeah.
We'll go to a guy like mighty mouse
where he fought a bog routine off and
bogatin off he out cardio the guy beat
his ass,
especially going into the stretch was
just completely out of work.
And um,
and at the end of the fight back with
[inaudible] pops hot for EPO.
Yup.
So even though this guy was on drugs,
mighty mouse is technique and cardio and
just as his ability to understand how to
pace himself through a five round fight.
Yeah.
No,
mighty mouse is.
He's a,
he's interested in it.
I know you've been a big fan of him and
I've always enjoyed watching that guy.
I mean I can't fight like that guy,
but to watch some of his techniques and
the way you use angles and footwork and
how he learns you in,
in his clinch game is,
is a nasty,
nasty.
You know,
I wonder if maybe you could give some
insight on this,
like you used to fight at 1:55 and now
you've got to cut to get down to one
$45.
A pretty big guy,
but mighty mouse is not a big guy and I
always wonder like could a guy like
could a light heavyweight or a
middleweight even,
could they possibly even fight like him?
Or is that a gravity thing?
Like is part of what's going on with
him.
The fact that he's so light,
like he can move faster.
He's got like more options as far as
equity can do.
Some people are blessed with a better
integrated in their body such as like a
neutral spine.
A lot of people have like lumbar
problems in neutral spine.
Ever watched mayweather.
He,
you don't ever see him lean and he's
just always in constantly good posture
and good position and just like in
wrestling,
if you're in good position,
more than likely you're going to win the
fight.
Mighty mouse,
he just has that type of movement and
integrate his whole body.
Whereas body moves as one,
it doesn't work against them.
There's not a like a lot of rattle and
his body safe.
He throws a kick,
he doesn't land awkward,
he doesn't it,
it goes.
He goes right back to a neutral base and
he's able to laterally move and
constantly have his body working for
him.
So I think him naturally,
he just has that type of gifts and
benefits of his body.
He's able to integrate his body to work
as one.
Therefore you don't waste a lot of
energy.
He has really fluid movement.
Look at a guy like Anderson Silva.
He's able to beat people just by keeping
his range and,
and just his movement of his body.
He doesn't,
he doesn't swing like a Mark Hunt or or
me where you know,
like I'll,
I'll throw a lot of powers and normally
I miss,
you know,
I'm just trying to,
trying to reach them,
but them guys,
they just use fluid movement and that's,
I think some people are just blessed to
have that integrated in their body in a
good neutral spine and a good solid
base.
And that's why they're able to connect
on their shots a lot more.
It's as convenient,
disconnected,
like,
uh,
say like a short circuit if,
if there's like a small,
like little detail,
like this cord right here,
say it's like it's like broken and
you're not getting the full amount of
energy as where if you have a solid base
and a good good spine,
you know how to integrate your body to
use as one,
there's going to be a lot more of a
sturdier connection and more flow.
Yeah.
Fluid movement.
I'm glad you brought that up because
I've always,
I've always thought that about like
efficiency,
that efficiency is very important.
And there are fighters that you see like
wasted movement or lot of slop into the
way they execute techniques and even if
they have power,
like sometimes like they're,
they're so awkward with the way they do
it,
but you've got to think that there's a
lot of waste as far as like the energy
expenditure.
But like,
so you think that that is a,
you said blessed.
So you think that that's a natural
ability?
I think
natural,
some of it occurs that some people are
able to integrate their body.
If you ever just look up people's
postures,
some people just kinda the they'll
slouch will kind of bend over
posture.
It's this thing is kind of actually is
it popping out?
It always does that.
We got a tape that down Jamie
and you know that like,
like you said,
it's a lot of wasted,
a lot of wasted movement as some people
are just more integrated with their body
so they are a lot more efficient,
you know,
granted then you do,
you've got to have the skills,
the cardio and everything else.
But I feel like if you have a good one
base and plus with the fight skills,
I feel like you're going to be a lot
more efficient and probably have
longevity in your career as well with
injuries and stuff.
Do you think that that's from childhood?
Like I've always wondered like there's
some children that start off doing like
gymnastics or there's been a lot of guys
in Jujitsu that have got into it that
come from break dancing,
which was kind of interesting.
Is a real recent,
we've seen a lot of guys,
but that ability to minute to move your
body like at a young age,
you develop like a real sense
of I want to add just coordination,
you know,
the just dexterity,
so many different attributes that you
develop when you're young and then your
body grows into it.
Yeah.
It's an intuition,
you know,
once you feel it.
Like I,
I work with a,
like a movement guy,
functional patterns for the long time
and I learned how to integrate my body
and to not waste movement in,
in,
you know,
to activate my core,
my glutes,
my growing all the way to my feet being
on my toes.
If you ever notice people walk like a
duck footed and stuff like that,
it's like all problems in their hips.
That's why you see like a lot of.
So I have like foam rollers and stuff
people roll out.
But you know,
once you release my Fascia,
there's,
there's corrective exercises you can do
to kind of reprogram your mind that
you've been working on such a
dysfunction.
You may not even know it.
And,
uh,
there's,
there's ways to do that.
You can integrate your body and
neurologically reprogram your mind is
like,
you know,
this is how I should be walking,
this is how it should be integrated,
my body.
And this helps out with posture and
breathing.
You know,
the ice man Hoff says lot of stuff about
this.
And uh,
it's,
it's real interesting facts to faccento
because this is for everybody.
People worked down at a desk,
slouching,
over typing all the time.
We got tight hip flexors there.
Their lean in poor diet,
you know,
it,
it like this a go.
It goes to anybody,
you know,
to learn how to integrate your body
power of posture.
And uh,
this guy,
uh,
naughty aguilar from functional
patterns,
really,
he taught me a lot about this and,
and movement and integrating your body.
And it just goes real deep.
Well,
there's,
that's a controversial subject,
right?
Movement coaches,
like there's a lot of people that get
involved with movement coaches and some
people mock it and some people say,
well,
you should just be spending that time
working on your fight training and your
abilities.
You know,
your,
your skill set and then just do cardio
and explosive exercises and then some
people say,
no,
you know,
that's good too.
But the,
the ability to move efficiently in odd
ways and carrier balance.
Now your guy,
he said it's a functional patterns.
That's what they call it.
Yeah.
The,
you know,
I,
McConnell McGregor has been,
been doing a lot of stuff with movement
and uh,
you know,
it's pretty good.
That's great.
Ido,
Ido portal,
that guy's a freak if you ever seen a
move.
Yes.
But here's what he lacks.
He lacks a integrating your body.
He doesn't understand the integration
part as it were,
a naughty aguilar with functional
patterns.
He teaches you how to kind of just sit
still integrating your body and just
hold these positions where I'm just
standing still or all my toes without a,
uh,
a lumbar extension or,
or,
you know,
if uh,
if I'm slouching,
he,
he keeps a neutral spine throughout his
whole movement.
So he's using his body as one and he has
a little bit more of an integrated
system as compared to just no one who
knows.
Even having to have a base and then just
go into this movement and you're doing
it all wrong while you have in Lombard
or you're slouching.
He believes in integrating that
techniques or your body works like you
said,
more efficiently instead of working
against you.
Well,
why do you think the Connor's doing it
wrong?
Like what?
What leads you to think that just,
uh,
just by his posture,
you can watch his posture or watch his
knee if his knee goes over his toe in
like a certain movement or he has like a
lumberyard and a spine as compared to if
you watch like a Naughty Aguilar,
he'll teach you how to do that same type
of movement.
But you'll see the little minor details
in,
in little millimeters of a difference
that,
that makes you integrated your body so
that your glutes are working with your,
with your core as you walk in.
We walk into everybody just does these
like,
you know,
dead lifts and it's not like a,
a good rotate.
As as humans we rotate,
we walk,
you know,
and fighting.
We move and he,
he integrates everything as far as your
core to your,
you're growing to your,
to being on your power to tow so that it
keep saying that power to like two toes.
What do you mean by the,
you know,
like say how you punched on like your
main two fingers.
The two knuckles that are index finger
and the finger,
right?
Yep.
And you know how you have like arches on
your feet and you're kind of walking
like,
look at my hands and you're walking like
that on the outside.
So then if I'm walking on the outside,
my knees like this,
say this,
this is good.
So now I'm integrating everything up to
my growing,
my glutes activated.
But if I'm walking on the outside,
your knee's gonna,
your knee's gonna your outer part of
your knee is going to be taken more of
the,
the load and the damage,
you know,
then you're not integrating or growing.
And that's how people end up actually.
Is this the guy?
This is him.
Functional patterns,
functional patterns.
What is his background?
Uh,
you know,
the guy's just a freak dude.
He knows a little bit about everything
and and right here you notice like he
doesn't really have any lumbar
extension,
which is like a lower back thing.
Everything is really integrated and it's
minor details in the corps and he's not
shrugging his shoulders.
He's,
he's using fluid movement and everything
that he does is rotational.
And what is his name again?
I'm sorry.
Naughty agular.
Naughty Aguilar.
And where's he out of a.
he's out of Seattle.
I met him in San Diego some years back.
We used to.
We worked a lot in just on a first we
had to fix my body a lot.
I was a of an elbow problems.
I was having all types of problems with
Tommy about myofascial release and then
I got into correctional exercises and
once he was able to fix my base I was
able to start moving and getting into
movements like this.
So what we're looking at folks for the
folks that are just listening is this
guy doing all this crazy movements with
kettlebells and dumbbells and jumping
around back and forth and see what all
these flips through the air right now.
Really interesting stuff though,
because you can land and they don't,
they don't go out,
they don't,
they don't do this.
And I have watched a idol.
I think that's his name and there's,
there's just these little details that
he doesn't have that he has that he
integrates.
Whereas knees don't,
his knees don't sway out.
Like everything is seriously in a
functional pattern.
Like everything he does,
he doesn't muscle anything to where like
you're,
you're lifting.
Everything is a fluid movement.
He's allowing the swing,
almost like a cheat to allow your body
to rotate.
And it's,
uh,
it's,
it's really,
uh,
it's really changed my life,
work working with this guy and the
things that I've learned and,
and,
uh,
the deficiencies in my body that I
really wasn't aware of back then that
I'm working with and you know,
I've
been fighting for a long time and I've,
I've been able to keep healthy and
injury free by doing a lot of these
movements,
myofascial release and working on my
posture.
Breathing.
You know,
people who are doing sprints at night,
they know your nervous system is still
in like a fight or flight mode and you
can't fall asleep,
you know,
such things as breathing to help that
out too.
I mean you've been here with iceman and
hear his stuff.
So I mean breathing's huge.
So I've learned a lot through this guy
actually.
So what you're saying is that doing
sprints at night is not a good idea.
No,
it is,
but I'm talking about,
you know,
if you figured out a little calmer self
doubt and that's breathing,
you know,
some people are like,
man I can't sleep at night but I,
but I ran,
you know,
it's like okay,
well you can do that by breathing and
just kind of calming your nervous system
down so that you can get that,
that recovery,
because if not you fall asleep.
Your body still thinks it's in fight or
flight mode and that they're still
sprinting as where you're able.
If you're able to breathe,
calm yourself down,
you get better sleep,
better rest recovery and the hormones
are going to take over your body and
repair it.
What I think about these things is
obviously this guy's very impressive.
I liked the way he's moving.
He's obviously very athletic and very
coordinated and you see when he throws
punches and kicks,
he's obviously had some martial arts
background as well.
There's some of these guys though.
I equate it to yoga.
There's a lot of real yoga people out
there that are really good at yoga and
they are dedicated to it and it's super
important to them.
And then there's the fuckers that are
fuckery.
There's just fake spiritual people and
they talk a lot of the yoga nonsense,
but they're really just fucking Weirdos.
And I see that a lot in these movement
coaches too.
Like I've talked to a few of them,
like,
Eh,
okay.
I,
I smelled fuckery.
If something,
something going on,
like there's an,
it's a weird Gig,
like to do that for a living.
What do you do?
Oh,
I teach functional movement.
What does that mean?
Uh,
it's just,
uh,
you know,
I show people how to move.
I know how to move.
What are you talking about?
He doesn't.
He was never like considered like a
movement coach,
you know,
he was never really considered like a
strength conditioning coach.
I went with him with pain management and
then it got into correctional exercises.
I mean this guy is,
he's actually had a eisman health come
hang out with him.
He's went and seen a.
The guy with the Venus project.
I mean this guy,
he's smart,
been all over.
I mean he,
he kind of does it all,
was really self sufficient.
He has a really good brain and
knowledge.
He,
he's not one of them like,
fuck,
are you guys.
I mean me and him had had our issues and
stuff before,
but we're,
we're cool,
but he's not one of them guys,
but I know exactly what you're talking
about this,
a lot of people in that,
this business mma business,
I'm sure you've dealt with a lot of.
They're moving in now.
The leather,
they always see the ido poor towels and
you know the move not guys.
They see these guys that are successful
work with guys like Carlos Condo to you
and then I see a few of these guys that
are trying to be one of these guys and
but this guy looks fucking legit as
hell.
Like you could tell by the way he's
moving like that is a really athletic
guy.
Yeah.
I don't.
I don't go around doing touch but shit,
you know,
and fights,
you know.
I mean I stick to stick to what I know,
but it is good to learn how to use pain
management to stay healthy Myofascia and
integrated your body so that you are
working efficiently and you're not
working against yourself.
I mean,
it's awesome to go through these
workouts that I do now.
I'm going to have a different strength
conditioning coach and we stick to a lot
of these functional movements,
athletic movements,
explosive movements,
and we do it with a good integrated
system to where,
you know,
if I,
if I go on banging on this tire and I'm
just recklessly and then I wake up in
the morning,
I'm like,
fuck man,
I got to spar and I'm feeling like crap.
I mean,
it's good to have your body working
efficiently,
using the right things that need to be
used instead of having all the small
muscle groups work in,
you know,
that's how.
That's how you get injured these days.
Know I was reading this post once on a
forum.
I think it might've been the underground
where someone was talking about lifting
weights and a how all their bad sparring
sessions come after lifting weights.
Like,
yeah,
Duh,
like you probably shouldn't be sparring
after you lift a.
like these dudes are talking about doing
like mega squats and deadlifts and power
benching and then trying to stay loose
and fluid.
It's not going to happen.
Your,
your,
your tissues all broken down and you're
exhausted and it's really a bad idea to
spar when you're like that because then
you know,
well,
what about mental toughness,
but you can't here.
You're not going to learn.
Your body's all fucked up.
You're supposed to be resting or if
you're doing anything he should be doing
like light drilling,
but something where you're forced to
react quickly and move.
That's a good way to get injured,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
people do that all the time.
You hear about these guys getting
injured all the time and you know,
just being self sufficient,
learning about little stuff like this
because it could help you out,
you know,
such as thing as just a little bit of a
foam rolling out and then a little bit
of correctional exercises that could
just help you out a lot more
efficiently.
And there's no.
I mean I've gotten in arguments where
I've went out to Arizona to see some of
my friends that ended up leaving
alliance and I,
you know,
I got into an argument a little bit like
a battle.
This guy is like trying to tell me to,
I need a my base to do this and I'm like
wearing a fight that I'm going to be,
you know,
10 feet.
My feet are this far apart.
I'm like,
no bro,
like I got to be within,
you know,
I can be able to rotate,
move,
you know,
with if I'm spreading my legs out,
that ain't doing nothing for me.
And I've,
I just,
I see a lot of people doing a lot of
meatheads stuff.
You know,
this isn't an interesting because you're
kind of,
it's a kind of an open ended thing when
you're a fighter because I see these
guys trying all this different stuff and
there's no right or wrong way.
Like here's a perfect example.
There's Robbie lawler who's a world
champion bad motherfucker and then
there's Stephen Wonderboy Thompson.
Totally different stance.
I mean totally different way of moving.
Both guys super successful and who
fucking knows what would happen if they
fought.
We really don't know until they fight,
right?
Yeah.
But if wonderboy,
Matt Robbins like,
Oh man,
you're doing it all wrong.
Yeah.
You know,
if he's trying to coach him,
but obviously he's not doing it all
wrong.
He's a world champion.
He's not doing it all wrong.
He's doing it perfect,
but is it the best way?
Ultimately you don't know and you won't
ever know until those two guys go at it.
And here's what's even crazier.
He might
beat wonderboy.
Wonderboy might be able to beat a guy
that can beat him.
It's weird.
I lived that life.
You.
It's weird,
right?
It is insane.
The home,
we're just watching Holly Holm and then
like shift change.
She gets beat by mistake and then she'd
beat Ronda Rousey type deal.
So.
Well,
Rhonda Rousey fought the perfect fight
for holly,
like charging adder.
And Holly's a great counter striker
where it shift Chenko.
If you watched that fight,
she did not lead at all.
She just hung back and waited and
enforced highly into her game.
Yup.
And uh,
you know,
it was just a bad night for holly.
I'm sure she'll be back.
But it's interesting tactically.
And,
and if you look at it from a strategic
standpoint,
like utilizing your skills to the best
of your ability in,
you know,
when you're inside the octagon and
figuring out what about what you do
matches really good against what she
does.
And Shevchenko just nailed it.
She figured it out.
Yup.
Crazy man.
That's the fight game.
It is the fight game.
It's a crazy game man.
And it's,
it's interesting you see people jumping
from one trailer to the other and just
looking for that.
And it's almost like you've got a
certain amount of time.
It's like you're playing musical chairs.
So like how much do you got into your
career?
You've got maybe like a good solid.
If you really take care of yourself,
you've got like 15 years unless you're.
Dan Henderson is abandoned too and he's
fighting for the fucking title.
He's gonna fight bisbing for the title
in London.
That's going to be madness.
And he says if he wins,
he's gonna Retire Dawn.
He should drop,
walk away,
carry out.
The one thing that he hasn't been able
to do is win the UFC gold.
But look man,
he's got as good a shot as anybody
watched that Lombard fight.
Yeah,
I did.
I was.
I was there,
but I couldn't believe it.
Dude.
I was going nuts.
I've been a fan of his for so long.
He's such an awesome guy.
Yeah.
Real,
real quiet,
chill and just amazing guy.
Dude is hard worker.
I mean,
it's awesome to see that.
Did you see as the instagram post after
he won,
he had an American flag on.
Does it said smoke that Cuban.
Oh
dude,
that was crazy.
I can't.
I mean Lombard's is scary,
do it.
I'm like,
no.
dude,
he's getting dropped.
I'm like,
no.
Henderson heard him first.
Henderson heard him first and he moved
in for the kill,
but Lombard wasn't done and Lombard
cracked him in Lombard had them on the
ground,
had him inside control it,
looked bad and then get the way knocked
them out too is so crazy with that.
Back Elbow.
Yeah.
Instincts,
man.
Oh yeah.
No one's ever done that before.
No one's ever knocked anybody.
I mean,
he was dead before he hit the ground.
Yeah.
No one's ever knocked anybody that with
elbow.
He,
you know,
he's going to follow up with a couple of
blows.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah,
you got to pull them off.
Lumbar.
Just scary dude.
And I was done at att one time helping
out,
uh,
Jorge Mazda at all.
And they're like,
hey,
whatever you do,
just don't spar Lombard.
I might think I was way bigger than me.
Like he would say,
he'd be like,
yeah,
he may try to ask you to farm.
Don't spar him,
you know,
it just comes in and he's just a tank,
you know?
And I'm like,
Fuck Dude,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to spar that guy.
Hell No.
He's a freak athlete,
man.
Him and Yoel Romero like,
I don't know what kind of rice and beans
they were feeding them down in Cuba.
Good rice and beans that you guys are
free suit.
Have you seen the new photos,
the most recent photos of [inaudible]?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
fucking Christ.
He looks like he's 250 pound dude.
If that guy tripped and fell,
I would seriously just run out the room.
They're like,
fuck that dude.
There's no way,
man.
I mean those guys are tapping before
doing.
It doesn't matter at all.
He just tears your shit apart.
That's insane man.
He's so fucking thick right now.
He's only like five,
seven and he's probably no bullshit.
Two hundred and 30 pounds.
He's enormous right now.
Yeah.
God bless him,
dude.
That guy's scary,
man.
Fuck.
Well,
now that he's not testing,
looking at him right there.
Jesus Christ.
I mean that's a legitimate 225 pounds at
five.
Seven,
five,
seven.
Yeah,
I'm way bigger than it,
man.
That's crazy.
It's crazy.
I mean,
dude,
I'm short.
I'm five,
eight and I stand.
I'm taller than that dude,
but he's like a foot wider than me.
Yeah.
And you get after I see you on the
audits and always,
always getting after it.
You know,
maybe after I retired from fighting,
I'm just gonna get on the juice and just
look like that as get back each class.
Do fucking strong man competitions.
Ankle locks all day.
Carry cars and shit.
Yeah.
Do you ever get caught on your car?
Paul Harris might be the guy that you
want right there.
He's ridiculously big right now.
Yeah,
that's definitely steroids.
One hundred percent for sure.
One hundred percent.
You don't gain that much weight.
I mean the last time he fought was like
a year ago and he was fighting in one 70
now and now.
I mean obviously a lot of guys would
fight at one 72.
Really weigh the one nineties,
somewhere around there and then they cut
weight to get down to one 70,
but that is just gigantic and do this.
That's too much,
man.
He's a fucking awesome Jujitsu player
too.
It's not just strong.
He's got some serious legit technique.
My uh,
where my guy who gave him a purple belt,
Dean lister,
you know,
he,
he's a,
he's been still going out and competing.
I know he just lost everything.
But uh,
it's just outstanding deeds.
He's very good dude.
He's a big dude,
but he rolls like a little guy and he's
just freakishly strong man.
Yeah,
he's a very smart dean.
Knows a lot about Jujitsu and he's one
of the reasons why,
you know,
the whole John Danaher,
Henzel Gracie team got so good at leg
locks.
A lot of that was the influence of Dean
lister.
Dean lister went down there and did some
training with them and dean has been a
leg lock master from the old days.
Like he was one of those guys that was
leg locking people in the early days of
Abu Dhabi.
Yup.
Back in the early two thousands.
You know,
when people like the leg lock game has
shifted over the last few years and it's
become incredibly dominant.
There's so many guys that are winning.
Like Jujitsu has become a largely like a
game of like 60,
maybe even more percent leg locks.
Especially no gate like Eddie Commons,
Gary Tonin,
all these guys from John Donohue camp.
There's so many guys down down there
that are just really talented at
attacking legs and not a lot of people
like that.
It's a sophisticated.
Yeah.
When you start playing with the legs,
you know,
scary.
No.
Yeah.
Nobody likes getting crippled,
but you know,
like Eddie Bravo had a really good
point.
He's like,
well,
is it okay if someone yanks on your
neck?
Is it okay if someone breaks your arm?
Like it's.
What is the difference?
Like just got to tap before you get
fucked up.
Yup.
Which is easier said than done.
Paul Harris is on there.
You tap all day.
But yeah,
he is tearing people's knees apart.
Yeah.
This kind of bullshit.
It is.
Well,
it's definitely bullshit when people
tap.
It is definitely bullshit.
When people tap.
Do you think there's anything that
should be changed about the current
rules?
Like if you look at MMA rules,
the way they stand right now,
like there's some people that think that
the uh,
knees on the ground issue,
if you,
if you don't know the story of MMA has a
rule where you can need someone to the
head if they're standing,
but if they put one hand on the ground,
you can't name in the hat.
So a lot of guys will put a hand on the
ground just to stop the knee and then
the lift that up and put it down like
they play like a little,
like almost like a game of like now.
Now I'm safe.
I got,
I'm holding.
Remember like old school wrestling.
You could hold onto the rope and they
would let,
let go of a whole.
Yeah,
Yup,
Yup.
10 counts stuff like all that.
Didn't they have that in like pancrase
to where in pancreas if someone was hold
onto a submission,
you could grab the rope and they would
let go of a submission.
I don't know.
I've never really watched too much
pancrase fucking feel like that was a
rule.
The rope.
Like oh I'm safe.
I'm safe.
It was something about that where if you
grabbed a hold of the ropes,
they had to let go.
No,
I think that's A.
I think it's a good rule.
I mean,
I actually just watched the fights over
the weekend.
Darren Elkins,
uh,
he just got need heart in the temple.
You don't me as a fucking illegal,
illegal.
And then the guy punches him after and
he falls down.
I'm like,
no way.
That was illegal knee.
And then,
you know,
he just shakes it off,
comes back and ends up beating the guy.
But as an animal,
yeah,
yeah.
He's a fucking hand on.
I fought that guy.
He just,
he's a tough dude.
He's took,
takes shots,
you know,
tough as nails and coming.
Yeah.
It's like you hit him,
he's like a Chris leave and he just gets
more fired up and keeps coming at you,
you know.
But uh,
you know,
as far as those rules,
I think that's kind of fair.
I mean,
unless,
you know,
I don't think UFC Fox wants to see
people getting head stomped and in their
prior roles,
you know,
and you know,
damn,
all them guys were juicing over there so
they're just taking people down.
If that was the case,
I just go juice uptake people down into
to start soccer,
kicking people all day,
you know,
that's scary.
It is.
Imagine somebody standing over you and
then you're just like,
fuck,
this guy is trying to stop me out.
I mean,
that's,
that's a scary thought to be thinking.
I don't know if I don't even want to be
fighting.
You
think that if it was legal that you
wouldn't think that way.
I mean,
think of all the stuff that you can do
inside the octagon,
you know,
think of all the techniques that you do
land like,
you know,
like that knee that you landed on Dennis
Bermudez,
that's about as powerful and knee as you
get hit a dude with on the ground
standing up.
No matter.
I mean,
that's a goddamn perfect knee.
You land on it and that was pretty
fucking spectacular.
Thank you.
But if that wasn't legal,
you know,
and then you did that.
Everybody be like,
Oh shit,
that shouldn't be legal.
Like perfect example is a Cyborg Santos
Michael Page.
Michael Page hit Cyborg Santos with a
nice so hard that he fractured his
skull.
His skull caved in and the fucking Mris
are insane.
I've never seen that in all my years of
watching fights and being involved in
martial arts.
I've never seen anybody's head caved in.
Yeah,
that's,
uh,
that's unfortunate man.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I can imagine some,
some trauma and some injuries and you
know,
and uh,
I seen sideboard was like,
oh,
it'll be fine.
It'll be fine in three months.
Yeah,
that's what you bro.
Yeah.
What?
No dude like,
look at the skull.
That's escaped.
That's nice.
That is nuts.
That's like,
reminds me of that movie concussion with
will Smith and he's talking about the
football players that are taking these
type of injuries,
you know,
and uh,
that,
that's bad man.
This whole fucking skulls.
It's crazy.
I've never seen that.
I've never seen that happen.
I didn't,
I thought that that area was so hard
because that's the area where I,
I guess like a lot of people break their
hand,
their hand right here.
They don't really break it on that area.
Yeah.
But I mean a,
a knee.
Yeah.
And you're kind of coming into it.
That's what it is,
right?
He was moving into it and it was really
just a perfect storm like him moving in
for the take down Michael Page,
leaping up at him and he's a bony dude,
you know,
he's a tall,
bony dude.
So that there's really not a lot of
quarter muscle that's going to hide that
knee and it's all bone on that dude's
head.
Yeah,
that's a nasty.
Nice.
Congrats to that guy.
That's,
that's pretty sick.
That guy's a bad motherfucker.
Want to see that guy in the UFC?
Yeah.
You break dance and shit.
Well he's just,
he was a point karate guy for a long
time and I've always said that there's
something about that ability to just
jump in real quick and get the fuck out
of there that these point karate guys
have their range is way different than
like a boxing.
That's kind of interesting that you
mentioned rob,
because if you ever watched Robbie,
he doesn't play the game.
He gets in that boxing range that way if
you throw a kick,
he's throwing hands.
Right.
And you know,
a wonder boy,
you know he,
he's a tall rangy dude,
but he keeps,
they keep that distance.
I mean,
you're a karate guy,
so that range is a lot different than a
Moitai or a boxing and,
and they're,
they're able to move really a
skillfully.
Well,
the point karate guys in particular,
I think that's the next stage of the
elite fighters are the,
like the background they come from.
We've seen guys that are successful that
come from Moitai.
come from wrestling,
but I think that point karate is going
to be the next stage because these guys
like page and Raymond Daniels who fights
out of glory days
are Rodriguez and my buddy,
my buddy Justin Lawrence is like that
uncomfortable karate background and he's
just fast and nasty and he keeps that
weird,
weird little Joe Rogan sidekicks or
scoggins who's fighting this weekend.
He's fighting Ian Mccall this weekend.
Always find.
That'd be interesting.
Yeah.
Scoggins is something too,
man.
He's got that crazy style too,
but he's got wrestling as well.
No,
he.
I first seen that guy fight.
He is good.
Good Cardio,
good wrestling.
I think if that guy just shows up with
the right mindset,
he's going to be one of the top guys.
He's a young kid to a young kid.
I think he's only 25 or 26 and super
technical like his.
His karate especially like he's got that
wide stance moves in and out real quick.
That's what's real hard to deal with men
because these karate style like where
they jump in and they're used to like
leaping in and then they tag each other
and get the fuck out of there quick and
then they score a point and then
everything stops and so they don't have
to have,
like in their sport,
they didn't have to have the kind of
endurance that you would need to like
try doing that at a Thai fight.
The ties are going to kick,
your legs are going,
but the thing about it is that these
guys have developed this incredible
ability to close distance really
quickly.
Then they pick up all the other skills
as well,
but everybody else has to play catch up
on that one thing that they can do the
leaping in and close the distance.
Yeah,
and you get a guy like pages.
Obviously a gifted athlete has been
doing it his whole life.
I mean,
he started martial arts,
I think something before it was five
years old,
so he's got years and years of
experience plus his body kind of
developed like we were talking about
people that started early with
gymnastics or with break dancing.
His body developed,
leaping in,
throwing kicks,
throwing punches.
He's got some sick dance moves,
you know,
so he's always on rhythm.
So you can't.
He's always on rhythm.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that's interesting.
That is interesting.
CEO.
I'm excited to see that guy in the
future.
Well,
I'm excited to see a lot of those guys.
Like I said,
Raymond Daniels as well,
who's a,
there's a great karate match where the
two of them,
uh,
fought in a point karate match,
but he took a look at him here.
Watch what page can do like that.
But he's,
he's hilarious too.
He just stands there and looks off in
the distance as the referee stopped the
fight.
He's obviously until he fought cyborg.
He's fighting people that have really no
business being in there with A.
Yeah,
he's on the Cyborg.
Took him down though in that first round
and presented some real problems,
but look at his distance.
May Look at that.
We were just talking about that,
but look at his ability to fucking leap
in,
but as also his ability to get the fuck
out of the way,
look at that.
It tax off of his back to.
He even won by foot lock.
This motherfucker's got arm bars.
I just mean that a style of a Roy Jones
used to have.
I mean he would just do that weird.
Let me just real athletic.
Exactly where Roy Jones was one of the
greatest boxers of all time and didn't
really use it.
Jab instead of used a leaping rep took
straight up leaping left hook.
Well he used the left Hook in place of
the Jab,
but you look like pages got crazy shit
like that right there.
His ability to close the distance and
look how quickly it gets out of dodge.
He's just so used to that style of
people leaping at him and getting out of
the way.
We'll do that one too.
Nasty.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean,
part of me likes the fact that he's in
beltour because I think Bella needs
stars because I think UFC needs
competition and I,
I liked Scott Coker,
I liked Bella tour,
I liked Jimmy Smith,
I liked the fact that they're doing well
and I would like to see like real
legitimate.
I'd like to see a real legit,
legitimate unification fight,
you know?
Yeah.
Start competing as teams.
That'd be,
that'd be sick.
Yeah.
What are you,
uh,
are you ever thinking about getting into
UFC anytime soon or?
Well,
I was not going to announce this until
assigned,
but I signed for at least one more year
is when I decided to do was um,
I was on the fence man.
So I just do too much shit.
That dude,
I'm too fucking busy.
After awhile I'm like,
I don't know if I'm doing myself or
anything.
I'm all the different things.
I do a disservice and I was real close.
I was like,
either I'm just going to completely bail
off of this or I'm going to try to
figure it out.
So I had a conversation with Dana.
We had a bunch of conversations and what
I decided to do was,
um,
no more international travel,
no more flying across the planet.
I just let Brian Take care of that for
Brian is fucking awesome.
I'm a big fan.
He's a good dude.
And as is,
uh,
Dan Hardee,
he's fucking awesome.
And Kenny,
I think those guys do a great job,
but for me personally,
it's just there's too much.
Like if I go to Brazil,
that's five days out of my life that I
can't do this and I can't do all the
other stuff that I do.
And then on top of that there's the
recovery time.
Like when I come back I'm fucking toast.
No,
I get it.
That fine just fucks my head.
So I decided to only do per view.
No more fox.
Um,
so I'm cutting down a lot of the events
I'm doing at least a year,
so it's like a year by year thing.
But uh,
at least one more year.
You got a lot of fan support and you do,
but you know,
you,
you probably want to start enjoying life
a little bit and cut,
cutting down eventually know and just
relaxing and enjoying life a little bit.
I bet.
Well,
you know,
what made me,
um,
tip the other way,
I was like,
I was like real convinced that it was
over.
I'm like,
I just,
I'm just going to be a fan.
I'll just do fight companions.
The Nate Diaz,
conor mcgregor fight and Holly Holm,
Miesha tate fight that night was so
crazy and so chaotic.
I walked out of there go,
how could I not do this?
How could I not be like I'm sitting
right there cage side for the craziest
shit in the sporting world ever.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I decided,
it was real recent man.
It was touch and go,
man,
I just didn't know what I was going to
do.
I was one day,
I'm like,
I'm done.
And the next day I'm like,
ah,
I don't know.
So I think the compromise is do less
events figured out,
but I don't,
I don't want anybody to think that I
don't appreciate it or I don't know how
lucky I am or I don't think it's an
amazing job.
I definitely do,
but I'm just,
I'm almost too lucky.
I have too many amazing jobs on the road
for you.
That's a lot of travel and just a lot of
travel,
lot of traveling,
a lot,
a lot of events and shit.
You done seen it all.
But one year was like 23 events.
I was like that's crazy.
That's like every other week and they're
gonna get more and more and more.
UFC is this getting freaking insane,
you know?
Then the big business deal and a lot of
lot of Shit's going down.
Even with the steroids.
Mark Hans going crazy.
You know,
someone needs to talk to mark man and
give him a call.
Dana.
Yeah.
I feel like someone should have talked
to mark immediately and sued that out
with him.
But.
But here's what I can tell mark.
If mark is listening,
they tested the shit out of Brock Lesnar
and they didn't know.
They didn't know.
The only way they would have known is if
you told them,
so you saw tested him.
He tested clean for a bunch of them and
then he tested positive for the one that
was like I think three weeks out of the
fight and then there was the other one
that he tested for post fight,
so I don't know what was going on.
I don't.
I mean it's just speculation,
but it could have been that he was just
really struggling and camp and his a
slick.
Here's what he took or allegedly.
Right.
He took estrogen blockers and the only
reason that anybody takes estrogen
blocker on purpose is to restart their
testosterone after they do a steroid
cycle.
That's why you take it when you take it
on purpose or unless you have some sort
of a biological disorder,
I would imagine,
where you have some sort of an excess of
estrogen in your body,
which I don't know why you would have
that.
I don't.
I'm not a doctor.
If I need to tell you that,
but I'm not a doctor.
I'm not a doctor,
allegedly.
so I don't know what the fuck was going
on,
man.
With Broccoli.
Who knows?
Maybe brock was like,
look,
I'm one and done in this bitch.
Yeah,
just gonna.
Just gonna make some fucking money.
How much?
How many?
How many weeks do they need to test me?
Okay,
so we're inside the window.
Fuck it.
If we test positive after the fight,
we test positive.
Like who knows,
you knows,
you know,
but that's the third time that's
happened to Mark Hunt doing,
you know,
and he's talking about this fighters'
union,
which makes things very interesting bro.
Well the problem with the fighters union
is fighters have been notoriously single
minded in.
They think about themselves.
It's going to be real hard.
It's not like baseball players,
you know,
it's not like you could get.
Let's also with baseball players union
or football.
It's like you have a team,
you know,
the UFC is the team,
there's not like it's,
you know,
it's not like they're the elite.
It's,
it's,
it's weird.
It's a different thing like boxing is
not going to have a box or a union
because then you're always going to have
like you have 10 vendors,
boxers make a shit ton of money doing.
They do make a shit ton of money,
but the people that make a shit ton of
money or the champions,
you know those,
the high level people in the high level,
people in mma make the same amount of
money.
The real argument is how much money
should the people that are putting on
the big shows like you,
the guys who were putting on fucking
incredible exciting fights,
how much should you make the headline of
card?
I know for me personally for my money,
if I'm watching Jeremy Stevens fight,
conor Mcgregor,
I,
I'm getting out my fucking popcorn.
I'm excited.
I'm paying my paper view money for that.
Let's make that happen.
40th five.
I think he's going to get whooped by
Diaz.
He thinks,
I think sodium.
Well,
he got whooped the first time,
but he was doing really well in that
first round.
I mean,
that first round was a big round for
connor and then he got tired.
Diaz had what,
10 days and he was drinking Tequila,
go 11 days and he was drinking Tequila
and I respect that,
but I think it's gonna be the same
seating situation.
I do.
Well,
there's a good argument there.
There's a good argument for sure.
Connor's got the one shot,
man.
He's just,
he's just like me.
He's like a rep could mean he's got that
one shot and put your lights out,
you know,
but he's like you at 1:45.
Whereas nate,
who has been fighting at 1:55 and one
slash 70,
his whole career is a bigger guy like
nate.
When I stand next to him,
he's a big guy,
man.
He's a big.
He's 55 is huge and you can take a shot.
Takes a fucking.
The only guy to put them out with Josh
Thompson and I've said time and time
again.
Josh Thompson,
one of the most underrated guys in the
sport.
Josh Thompson.
The timing just wasn't right for him.
Yup.
Like school.
Yeah,
he's old school,
but he's fucking good man.
He was fucking good.
And when he fought nate,
he was just on his game and he had
kicked him.
Yeah,
Josh Thompson had kicks anybody.
He's finishing up,
you know what I mean?
No,
he's an athletic dude,
man.
That guy has been around a thing before
the UFC.
He cut out the 55 division,
you know,
and that's when I was kind of coming up.
I was like,
I'm going to fight it 70.
Yeah.
Like fuck it,
I want to be in UFC.
I guess I got to go up to one 70.
So I was taking fights at like 65.
We'll explain.
People know what you're saying.
Is the UFC didn't have a 1:55 division
for a while?
Yeah,
they could.
They got rid of it.
Well this is,
you know,
a lot of people don't realize when they
see the sport now and it's gigantic.
It's huge.
When you were first fighting and
competing man,
it was.
You had to really love what you're
doing.
It wasn't like there was some Ronda
Rousey,
conor mcgregor pay days that people were
getting,
you know,
when you hear about the paydays these
people are getting now,
like John Jones,
his manager was saying that John missed
out on at least $10,000,000 for his
fight with Daniel Cormier and then Jon
Anik was saying that over the two years
it's probably going to cost him as much
as 30 to $40 million when you factor in
all the super fights he could have had
in two years,
which is just fucking crazy.
Yeah,
dude,
he's one of the pound for pound best
manager.
So he's his own worst enemy I guess.
Well for him it's another weird one.
So that was an estrogen blocker thing,
but a doctor,
but I'm not cycling off it.
People cycling body changed to it,
you know,
and that,
that's,
that's kind of crazy.
He got,
he got real big and he was like into
lifting a lot.
And then lifters,
man,
those guys love that stuff so.
Well,
the lifters to the problem is you get
some bro Science,
you know,
you get some dudes in the gym,
Bro.
I'm telling you bro,
you cannot test positive broke because
what you're gonna do,
you're going to drink three gallons of
cat piss and you're going to go in there
like three gallons.
Yeah.
Do do it to be a champion to champion.
Like they'll tell you some wacky shit.
This guy was telling that if he
was trying to tell me that all these UFC
guys,
man,
they're tested positive.
I know how to get them off that man.
I go,
no,
you don't.
You don't date.
You saw Lance Armstrong,
one of the,
one of the richest guys.
You'd always given speeches and high
five and the president.
If that guy can't be Jeff Novitsky,
I don't think anybody,
you know,
I mean.
Well,
here's the thing about Lance Armstrong
never tested positive.
You have to realize that Lance Armstrong
He had just stayed,
never caught him.
He admitted guilt.
Admitted.
Yeah.
He had admitted,
but they know the walls are closing in.
All these people were suing them.
He was suing people.
There's a lot of chaos going on.
He just wanted to go and clean.
There's no,
there's no drug tests that show that
Lance Armstrong was doing anything.
Yeah,
he was definitely doing some shit
though,
which is really kind of crazy.
I don't get why people want to go ride a
bike for that long.
And I mean honestly,
you know,
since you saw it as kind of came in,
I've done a lot of cardio and stuff,
but I'm like,
you know,
I've ran up to a,
like a little bit over two hours or
around two hours and uh,
you know,
I don't want to go ride a bike for
fucking seven,
eight hours and get up again.
And I'm like,
fuck that.
I'm going to,
I'm going to do some epo just so I can
just go out and just get it for $70
million.
It's a child's fucking method of
transportation.
Do some porn bro.
Just go kill it for seven,
eight hours.
Like why are you going to.
I mean,
that's just nuts.
I don't.
But to each their own,
I'm.
Look what it is is a mental toughness
thing.
It's like their ideas,
like they're going to keep grinding it
out.
One other people are going to slowly
back off and fade and going to keep
going.
Nope.
That's the true break through break.
That's what I find in running and doing
these long runs and stuff throughout
camp.
That's a sets a different pace and that
that is right.
The mental edge that you have from
running and you're just like,
it's insane.
You almost got to be a madman,
but you only know that when you actually
complete that type of a long run and you
endure that type of thing,
other everybody else can kind of look
back at me and you're crazy.
Like we don't do that,
but you are kind of crazy in your head
and you're like,
yeah,
fuck yeah,
I am crazy.
I did do that.
Well,
you know what?
Put you on another level.
It's one of those things where you just
constantly try to find your limit.
Like,
I'm going to hold my breath for a
minute.
Hmm,
I did it.
Let me see if I can do two minutes.
Okay,
what's the world record?
And then you start trying for whatever
the fuck the world record is.
And like I have my buddy campaigns,
he does a ultra marathons.
He's done 100 miles and now he's doing
200 miles in August.
He did a 100 miles last month to get
ready for 200 miles next month.
Damned like what?
That's intense.
Two days,
two days of running.
That's crazy bitch retarded,
right?
Yeah,
he's retarded.
But I bet that guy's probably cool to
hang out while he's the fact that I bet
he's just a wild madman,
you know,
when you go hang out with them and
probably hear some of his ideas and his
beliefs.
Well he's just mentally.
It's tough as it gets.
And he's just trying to find his limits,
you know,
he's always trying to find his limits
and he can't find his limits at 100
miles,
which is fucking bananas.
That's all trying.
How does,
how does he.
Forty eight,
48,
Leo,
you know what they say?
They say that,
um,
those marathon or ultra marathon,
like a lot
of them are older because it's not,
it's not something that young guys excel
at,
like you're not going to find like a 20
year old athlete.
It's really good at running 100 miles.
It's dudes that have been divorced and
had their heart broken and went
bankrupt,
came home and the girlfriend was fucking
their best friend that I've been there
in high school.
Bad guys have that extra gear.
Those guys that are,
that are 30,
30 years old and they're there,
they're crying.
It's like,
Bro,
get over it dude.
It's all right man.
If she's,
if she wants to go,
she's going to go and bang,
you know,
30 black guys or she wants to do.
So that'd be black guys always.
Whenever I remember his word it.
Did he see him crying?
I mean,
I went to that in high school,
man.
I was like,
all right,
that's enough of that,
you know,
at a young.
I'm glad I did because some people
mentally they just don't get it.
And then when they get a little bit
older and they go through it,
they're just like,
whoa,
whole life just changed.
You got to learn how to get your
heartbroken recover.
Like if you don't get your heart broke,
you'll never understand what it's like
to get your heartbroken.
Like it's,
it's a really important thing.
Like when it's happening,
you feel like the world's over.
Then you
looking back,
it's hilarious.
Like I look back on some heartbreaks
that I had when I was 19.
I'm like,
yeah,
I think it's funny now that I was being
such a bitch,
you know,
that I was crying a writer,
a like a load back note.
I remember that man.
Of course,
every guys,
every girl to the money and you look
back at it,
but do it when you're going through it,
man,
you're like,
fuck,
I need to just shoot myself.
I fucking can't stand this dude.
Like,
speaking of shoot myself.
Did you see that video?
That fucking rapper that shot himself in
the mouth around video.
See that stupid asshole.
This guy made a video of him.
He put like a gun next to his cheek and
shot a hole through his face on camera.
I think he's going to get more hits now.
Yeah,
because you got shot.
He was saying he doesn't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck what policy it.
Watch this guy.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Play it.
Does that a starter pistol or was that a
bullet?
Because here's the thing.
He's in his car.
This is one thing that leads me to think
that this is a starter pistol because
he's in his car.
Right.
So where's that bullet going,
man.
Straight through his mouth.
Yeah,
but he doesn't hold it at the end of the
video.
Did he though didn't go through his
other cheek?
Did he though?
Let's watch.
What's his name?
Casper night.
Is that his name is dummy.
Fuck.
I don't give a fuck about nothing in
gangster.
I the Holy Shit.
I didn't swallow anything.
We didn't go.
He didn't swallow running.
We need to go
whatever bucket.
If I die,
fuck it.
You're not going to die from that pussy.
Huh?
What is this Guy Thinking?
People?
People do this stuff nowadays and it's
just really kind of discussing where
does this guy's parents at home doing
math?
Seriously,
man,
I the fucking bullshit.
You just shot yourself video.
See,
it's possible that that was a 22.
It was a very small gun obviously
because the sounds like it was a very,
very low low volume sound.
So I think that was probably like if
anything it was a 22 and if he did
swallow the bullet,
I mean maybe I guess maybe it doesn't
make sense that looked like it came out
the other side disturbing to watch.
It's not really that you just shot
himself something,
but just his attitude,
what is wrong with you man?
Not,
not good,
not good.
That's not a goal in individual with.
The crazy thing is that guy might get
like success for that.
Like he made some posts about it where
he was like,
y'all got played or something like that.
Like what?
Okay.
You see the post that he wrote,
he's got a whole post after it.
A doctor stitched him up.
A doctor's like,
I'm okay,
know disturbed well,
you could take a starter pistol by the
way and it will blow a hole through your
mouth.
There's a guy who,
uh,
was an actor when I was on this TV show.
His friend was on the TV show with me
and the guy had died.
He was playing around with a blank and
you know,
he had a like for a movie and he put the
thing up to his head and didn't realize
that the amount of force that comes out,
just the air a fractured his skull and
killed him.
Oh yeah.
From a blank.
Brandon lead die like that.
Right?
Like Brandon Lee died because it wasn't
a blank.
There was some sort of a particle that
was inside the blank and it shot him in
the chest.
And the conspiracy theory buckle up
black helicopters that the conspiracy
theory is the same people that killed
Bruce Lee wanted to kill brandon Lee
because brute,
like this is Joey Diaz believed.
What does the dog.
I'm telling you,
you don't get away with those fucking
Chinese triads.
You can't dodge that bullet.
Because he was telling me that
he was like,
exactly this voice,
this motherfucker,
he was,
he was saying that um,
that Bruce Lee had some sort of a deal
to do movies for the Chinese triad and
he was doing all these movies for them
and then left to come America to
be a big time movie star.
And when he came over to America to be a
big time movie star,
he fuck those people that he had this
deal with.
They were like,
Oh really?
And then they came and got him.
But man,
dude,
I honestly do that growing up,
you know,
not being racist or anything.
But I've had a lot of late,
no Asian friends and stuff man.
And they do,
they get violent and they get into like
wolf packs quick.
I've seen.
Oh yeah,
I did security one time man.
And I seen like two dudes fighting and
then it turned into the whole Asian
community just throwing bottles,
shooting out in the parking lot,
you know,
just a throwing cueball's chairs,
more bottles in disguise this laying
down like fetus position.
And I've seen him just do a lot.
I mean,
they stick together and I seen a guy
actually stabbed some dude and then get
this.
This guy comes out and he's like,
he's like,
I just got stabbed and he's come up to
this police officer.
Police officer pulls out his gun and
he's like,
get on the ground.
He's like,
Bro,
I just got stabbed.
He's like,
get on the ground.
And the guy's like squirting blood out
his back and then like,
like 50 Honda civics and accurate as
Bra,
just all taken off.
And the guy was like laying on the
ground telling them to get on the
ground.
I Dunno man.
De Moines,
Iowa.
I saw a fucking video yesterday of a
cop.
They just gave this kid like $180,000 a
cop hit him.
He's on his motorcycle.
The kids stopped at a light.
The cop hits him from behind.
Okay.
That he falls over,
get the cop,
gets out of the car with his gun,
drawn the kids like what the fuck?
The cop kicks him in the chest and
breaks his collarbone and then tells
them to get on his knees and the kid
gets on his knees.
All captured on fucking video.
In what?
What was the.
What was the cause of him getting pulled
over?
Nothing.
There was no,
cause he's the only boy.
He was on a motorcycle.
Watch this shit.
No,
this isn't it is it?
It goes way ahead.
Oh,
that's what you sure.
This is the same one because the other
one was at an intersection.
Jamie.
Oh,
this guy seems like he's flying.
Are you sure it's the same video?
Yep.
Well that's the case.
And this kid,
it was a speeding thing.
Oh there.
Oh,
okay.
Well that changes everything.
Yeah.
So they,
they bumped him on purpose.
Okay.
Let's see how this goes down.
Well,
I'm changing my folk tune right here
that said this was speeding
motorcyclist.
Gee,
he's not stopping.
Oh,
they fucking hit him on purpose.
oh yeah.
Oh,
okay.
This is different.
This is falling off your little bike.
Yeah,
it's a bump.
So Watch.
He's like,
Whoa,
we'll do.
Oh,
a little front kick,
a little 300 fat.
So gay karate kid.
That was a terrible thing.
He's holding the gun gangster to right
here.
He's slept too many fucking boys in the
hood movies.
Hey,
you know what,
man,
that changed my tune.
People need to just shut their mouth
when it comes to the authority,
you know,
and I think of these other countries.
I'm like,
other countries don't do that because
they will sever your head off if you're
filming
them,
they're going to cut your head,
you know,
people come here and they're like,
they get in this mix.
The cops trying to like,
hey,
you know,
like you're coming with us and then
they're like,
people recording and then they don't
listen and the cop has to use force,
you know,
and they're just.
People just don't really respect her.
Granted,
there is other sides.
But did,
did see the guy in Florida that got shot
while he was lying down with his hands
up talking to.
He was a therapist and he's totally
unarmed lying on his back and the cop
shot him and then he's like,
why'd you shoot me?
He's like,
I don't know,
like,
and then the cop changed his story.
The cop completely changed the story
after it was over,
you know,
look,
there's good and bad,
but I didn't see the full video of this.
I only saw the end.
Which really makes you think like when
you,
you see a lot of these interactions that
people have with cops.
Like what led the cop to be so fucking
ramped up?
Well here now you understand that guy
was risking all sorts of people's lives
lives by riding that motorcycle,
like a fucking maniac.
And then the cop got ahold of him.
He bumped him to knock him off the bike,
but that kid was fine,
but that kid got $180,000 for that
breaking the law.
He gets 180 grand for a weak ass bitch
front kick.
Terrible front kick too,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
He had a glock though the gangster
glock,
you know,
but you know,
some,
some people,
you know,
the cops that,
not all of them because I have uncles
that are cops.
They're great people,
but they're just like us.
You know.
And it makes them no different and some
people I feel like they get a little
power power trip
100 percent times.
Been polite to cops and I've been
treated very rudely,
you know,
and then there's times where I've been
polite and they've been applied or they
let me off on like a speeding ticket.
I was speeding,
you know,
but there's times where I've seen cops
just look like maybe they got bullied in
high school and they take advantage.
But I mean that's just human nature.
What do you want?
It was in an unmarked Camaro that looks
like this.
And he didn't have a siren outside.
They only had his lights on.
He didn't even know he was being chased.
Oh,
well that's nice.
That's what the motorcycle.
I said,
well that makes sort of sense more.
Send a video of him in and out.
I don't know.
Got One hundred 80 grand.
He's lucky.
Yeah.
He's still driving a Douche bag.
I mean if you want to drive like that,
go on a fucking raceway man.
You can take that bike on a race way.
You're not supposed to cut in and out of
traffic the way he was doing,
going ridiculously excessive speeds.
The video,
like when he's cutting off cars and
stuff like that.
That's,
that's how people die and not
necessarily you.
That happens here in la all the time.
I was driving down here from San Diego
and I mean I do that all the time at
those bikers,
man,
they,
they zone in and out and I don't hear
him come behind me because they're
flying and I'm in between traffic and
they combine almost like scraped your
mirrors and then they're getting mad at
you and you're like,
Bro,
I don't see.
You know,
I got a little bit of music plan.
It's not like real loud,
but it's like I can't hear you into
like,
you're right there.
That's why it's sometimes just to
release those.
Harley Davidson's
are so loud,
like there's a.
I saw a bumper sticker that said loud
pipes save lives.
They really do.
It makes a big difference.
Make sense that they have those,
those loud pipes like that.
But,
you know,
I think that cops are just like you and
me and one of the things that I think we
should all take into consideration is
the amount of people that they deal with
on a daily basis that are criminals that
are violent,
that are dangerous,
that there's just so much shit they have
to deal with.
I just don't think most people are
qualified for that job.
I think that job should be for people
that are like ex military that are solid
as a fucking rock,
I think it should be super high paying
and it should be a really well respected
job.
And I think those people should be like
integrated in whatever community that
they're enforcing.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
I was actually telling this,
I don't even know if I told my coach
today,
but I was thinking,
I was like,
man,
I want to go and help out the cops in a
little bit of like candy,
like combat and go in and help them out.
Because I mean,
a lot of people don't know.
I mean,
if you come up to me and I'm not
thinking anything,
but I can just quickly pull out a gun
and shoot you and sometimes those cops
don't know,
you know,
and they're trying to be nice and then
they get killed on the spot or you know,
they may not know and they killed them
and maybe it wasn't a gun,
but I mean,
that's a quick little within,
you have to make a huge decision and
just such a matter of seconds,
it's going to be me going home and,
you know,
not just like a fight,
you know what I'm saying?
Hey man,
it's going to be me going home in the
winter and feed my family as compared to
you,
you know,
that's,
that's life or death situation.
So it's,
it's definitely scary.
I feel like they definitely need a
little bit better education on the
training and uh,
you know,
if anybody in San Diego is listening to
this or any police,
you know,
I'd love to come help,
I'm sure like dominick Cruz and the
guys,
we'd love to come help and uh,
you know,
and have you guys come into the gym and
just keep the community safe,
crazy
be mandatory.
The cops have at least some sort of
martial arts training because uh,
you know,
I was talking to big John Mccarthy about
this where he was telling me how few
police officers can even physically
defend themselves.
He's like,
there's a lot of guys that just don't,
they don't know anything and they don't
work out at all overweight.
Yeah.
And if,
if shit goes down,
like they're helpless.
And these are the supposed to be the
people that are supposed to serve and
protect.
Yep.
Know.
And John obviously he's a giant Dude and
plus a black belt in Brazilian jujitsu
and been around martial arts alive.
But you know,
when you're dealing with someone who is
a explosive,
dangerous person that might be a felon
their whole life and you're someone who
has no experience at all in any kind of
hand to hand combat situation,
you're,
you're in a bad spot.
Yeah.
You know,
a lot of them don't know.
And I've even been in a,
like a training with the army and
military and wounded warriors praying.
I mean I've trained a lot of people in,
a lot of people don't even know the
basis of just hand fighting in
Bellingham fighting is very important.
Especially if someone's holding a gun,
you know,
they don't even know that chokes.
And it's like,
wow,
that's crazy.
They don't know basic stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
Because what if they ran into a guy like
me out there,
you know,
like one of those villains,
like the guy from Morocco who robbed a
bank,
you know,
it was just like a legit criminal.
I mean,
which some are wholly Marie.
Yeah.
Lee Marie,
you know that you run into that guy and
he's like,
he's like being all cool,
boom.
All of a sudden he's like trying to snap
your neck.
Well,
that guy was crazy because he was super
skilled,
but a fucking legit gangster.
Criminal criminal pulled off,
uh,
the biggest,
80 million
armed heist in European history.
Right.
Never found a single dollar.
Is that true?
Yeah.
They never found the money.
Never found the money.
Oh my God.
Who's got the money lead Murray,
who's really.
Well,
he's in jail now,
right?
But Rocco.
Yeah.
Pat Miletich shut and hold a training
coach of mine.
He keeps in touch with them.
Was like a pen pal.
I don't know if he still does or not,
but a dearly dearly.
I was watching pat today.
I was watching him.
He was,
um,
I watched lion fight.
I'm a big Fan of lion fight.
He was doing commentary for lion fight.
You.
Pat was saying that he was about to do
100 mile run and I was asking him.
I was going to mention that.
Yeah,
yeah.
I seen him on facebook.
I follow them and I guess he put out
like this,
like little lists,
like he's going to do like do a four
mile,
10 mile and then he's basically like
building up like 15,
20 miles that he's going to do 100 mile
run.
But like,
you just do that slowly just by building
like a little base and getting himself
ready for that.
But that's a.
Why was he doing that?
I don't know.
He's,
he's getting older.
I'm just fucking with divorce or I don't
know,
man.
You never know.
Maybe it's just looking for a new
challenge.
Yeah.
Retired from fighting,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
I seen Don Frye recently just get
knocked out recently,
but you know,
I mean I feel like yeah,
he got knocked out by one of A.
was it dog?
The bounty hunters,
a security guys that was really old.
Video was from a long time ago.
Don Don was really drunk.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And he got into some sort of a fight in
a hotel with some dude seen that,
I think that was really old.
There's always that dog in you,
you know,
I mean you've probably been away from
competition for awhile,
but you still like to grapple and just
get after it,
like in your gym,
always see you hitting it.
But I mean just as a man or a
competitor,
you always have that type of.
I mean eventually you gotta let it go
and eventually your time's going to
pass.
But I mean you're always gonna have that
drive and you know,
running or doing something like that or
swimming is always going to probably
keep that passion,
that drive,
that still in use.
So it's probably good to kind of release
that and go out there.
And I mean definitely.
I think it's definitely good to push
yourself in some sort of a way because I
think we're,
a lot of guys were,
it's really a classic story with boxers
especially.
They stopped competing and then they get
into hard drugs and it happened with Joe
Lewis had happened with um,
a set white guy.
I understood which one fluid done,
knocked him out.
He was doing cocaine with some hookers.
You got them on video.
What's his name?
Man,
oh,
Ricky Hatton.
Yeah.
I was thinking of um,
goddammit,
the dude who,
uh,
Cassius clay beat Sonny Liston,
Sonny Liston,
he died of a drug overdose to.
They didn't know a lot of those guys.
They,
they stopped fighting and there's also
the,
the thought of,
you know,
you have a long career of getting hit in
the head and then you want to self
medicate efforts over like a lot of
these guys,
they have um,
issues with their,
their,
their systems,
like the endocrine systems,
they have issues with the pituitary
gland.
A lot of depression comes in and they
start,
they start trying to fix that without
alcohol or fix that feeling with cocaine
or prescription and prescription drugs.
Yeah.
Those are the worst.
What prescription drugs are a real
problem because a lot of guys get
injured and then,
you know,
they go to a doctor or they got a
problem,
their lumbar or something like that or
trying to imagine the disc.
Yeah.
It's dangerous,
man.
I watched that episode ballers and uh,
the Rock Johnson,
he's always smashing them vicodins and
you know,
those nfl guys talks about that.
You've seen that show.
It's pretty sick.
Show the rocks man.
And uh,
you kind of see that and you're like,
man,
that kind of makes sense that,
you know,
most likely that they are shooting them
up and get back on the field.
You got to win the game and you know,
when you're in that moment you're not
thinking about it.
But then in the longevity,
you know,
like that movie concussion,
the one guy from the steelers was going
down the opposite way and then smashed
it into a car.
It was wanting to kill his family and
just snaps out,
you know?
And that's just a,
that's just crazy men.
Well,
you know,
head injuries or no fucking joke man.
And that was one of the things that I'm
brock was talking about with wwe that
earlier in his career he had issues
where he was,
you know,
those guys are fucking flipping each
other and landing on.
People could say that's fake wrestling
these,
that term,
fake wrestling.
Those fucking flips a real man.
The impact is real.
Those guys getting body slammed,
that's all that all counts.
Cutting themselves.
And then,
you know,
tax like mankind used to do and fallen
off the cages and the tables and then
those,
uh,
those metal chairs and they would just
bash them over.
That's real man.
That,
that's a real.
That's real.
Yeah.
That's.
I'm like,
dude,
that's crazy.
It is crazy.
And you see that a lot of those guys are
suing the wwe now.
Like Jimmy superfly snooker was wearing
a suit and going to court and they're
suing the wwe for still around.
Superfly still around,
I guess probably got some head injuries.
Didn't use to jump off the rope and like
the head.
But yeah,
that was his thing.
One of the most dangerous moves to would
get the super fly.
He would stand on the top ring and fly
into the air jungle show days.
Boom.
Your fucking brain.
Jostling around inside is coconut.
Yeah.
He had that gene simmons hair.
Dude,
that's.
He was my favorite man.
My manager was just telling me about
jake the snake.
Uh,
there's a documentary on Netflix and
it's just sad that that guy he went to
alcoholism to depression was in a
trailer just from having everything to
those,
those injuries and self-medication into
drug and alcohol addiction and stuff.
It's a hard word.
Hard road.
That's that life of being a pro wrestler
is so fucking difficult.
They don't get nearly enough credit for
what they do.
Those guys were on the road sometimes
260 plus days a year and they are
throwing each other through fucking
doors and smashing you over the head and
fucking all the stunts that they have to
do all the flips and all the craziness
while lifting like meat heads to
juicing,
juicing up,
lifting like crazy.
It was crazy,
man.
Yeah,
it is crazy.
But
it's a lifestyle.
Yeah.
I mean
they chose it.
I guess.
GotTa love it.
Yeah.
You do.
You know when you got,
you got to love it and that's really,
that's ultimately their decision.
It is,
I guess,
but I think super fly was saying that I
don't see.
Don't want to know.
It's kind of crazy.
This is really recent,
but you know,
when I was a kid I was in high school in
the eighties and super fly was the man,
you know,
he was like the big deal and when I was
in high school,
so no one knew shit about concussions
back then.
No,
no one knew anything about cte.
We never heard of that term.
We heard of brain damage,
like sky's get punched drunk.
That's what we heard.
But no,
but we always thought,
ah,
you could kind of tell see a guy like
starting to slur his words.
It's time stop and you'll get better,
you know,
but that's why we didn't know that you
get it from playing football.
You never heard of that,
right?
Nope.
Nobody even talked about.
Denied in NFL.
Covered it up.
Yeah.
Well that was,
I didn't see that movie concussion,
but that's what it's based on.
Right?
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
but at the same time,
the guys,
they want to go out there,
they want to play,
they want to,
they want to compete.
You know,
this is a natural drive,
but I mean you are put yourself at risk,
but you know,
at the same time we could all just go
out of here and get in a car accident
and die just so of course,
you know,
there's a lot of things that people do
that they really,
really enjoy that are risky.
Are we supposed to tell people they
can't fucking surf anymore because
there's sharks out there?
Yeah,
I mean,
what are we supposed to do?
You tell people they can't race cars
anymore.
He can't.
It's uh,
I mean,
no one could talk about it better than
you.
I mean,
you're a professional cage fighter.
It's one of the most dangerous jobs in
all sports.
I started to just fighting for,
just to kind of defend myself going
through different schools and getting
bullied and you know,
I started fighting,
fighting,
but then once I kinda got into the sport
and my uncle who kind of led me into
this,
my grandpa,
and then I started fighting at 16 years
old and I was fighting like grown men
and adults and a mma fights in the May.
And no holds bar is like we'd go to a
bar and there'll be like pool tables,
people be drinking beer.
I couldn't even get in.
You had to be like 18 to get in.
I was 16,
but my grandpa,
he was super cool.
Nice guy.
He allowed me to come in and I was
fighting these grown men and I was like,
pop brought you to fight in a cage.
Yeah,
when you were six.
Because he knew that I was legit.
Man.
GRANDPA.
He was,
he's passed away.
But yeah,
he uh,
he was getting great grandpa.
Yeah.
He boxed and wrestled throughout his
life and was a competitor and wow,
he seen me getting a couple of street
fights
and he's like,
he knew I was wrestling.
I'd always kind of get scrapped and rest
because I used to just cross face people
real hard and I'd always kind of get
into a little scrap and match or
whatever.
And uh,
he invited me out there and Josh near
was the man out there at the time and I
was 16 years old and I go out there and
I just start.
I started fighting and then like once I,
once I did that and then like my first
fight and then my,
my older sister,
she was there and like,
she uh,
there was like these strippers that were
there,
I mean had huge boobs,
you know,
I never seen anything like that.
She's like,
oh,
this is my brother.
He just won.
They were like,
Oh hey,
like,
what's up,
you know?
And I'm like,
man,
like this is the life,
right?
Just knock somebody out now.
Now girls are hitting me up,
you know?
And then like I was like the man in
school and I did it and I did it just
because I loved it.
And you don't know.
Now I look back
today and I'm like,
man,
here I am making thousands of dollars
traveling the world,
meeting people sit down here to the
podcast,
Joe Rogan.
I'm like,
Damn Dude.
Just finding really took me very far.
I feel like I found my passion.
But when you caught a wave,
you caught it like right when it was
taken off.
And like we were talking about,
you were in the UFC before there was
even a 155 pound division.
You were thinking about fighting one 70.
And I grew up old school.
Josh near old school as fuck.
That's a tough dude.
That's another dude.
Doesn't get enough credit.
Josh neer.
He's a talented motherfucker,
man.
Tough as nails my best man.
That's my guy.
Do My right hand man.
Good Dude.
Good fight around.
Do you ever see that video?
I'm sure you've seen hell of a father to
dude.
He's just,
he's a good dude.
He's actually a pretty smart with his
money.
A lot of people thought he was stupid
just because he's quieter people.
What's up with them?
Like I just don't want to talk to
people.
He just thinks a lot of people are
bullshitting,
you know,
which mainly motherfuckers are.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
He's real conservative and then.
But once you get to know them,
dude,
he's the funniest dude.
He's always prank and people are really.
Yeah,
he's a jokester and he was really good
with his money and he,
he,
uh,
he paid for the way for a lot of Iowa
guys coming out of Des Moines.
We went up to the military,
which I followed him and uh,
I wouldn't be here today if it wasn't
for him.
That's a good store.
And the guy's an animal.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of the way he fights to
fight for a very,
very smart and very tough to go.
Relentless Dude.
Do you see that?
I'm sure you've seen it.
I was going to say the video of some
dude came into the gym and challenged
him some big ass dude and he beat the
fuck out of the guy he had.
He had a story about that guy just of
bullying him.
He said that the guy was huge.
Real cool.
Yeah.
You say you met him out at the bar and
he's like,
Hey,
let me buy you a drink.
Let me buy you a drink.
And he's being cool at the bar and he's
just like,
man,
this guy is kinda weird.
So he kind of separated,
didn't have any confrontation and the
guy was being all cool.
He says as he was leaving,
he's like,
man,
I went to go get some girls.
You know,
he's like this guy,
there's a lot of dudes at the bar like I
left.
He's like,
I look on my phone,
it's on facebook disguise.
Like if you,
dude I'll beat your ass,
blah blah blah.
Like you don't know me.
And Josh is like,
okay Bro,
I don't even know you,
but you know,
I thought it went nowhere.
He meets the guy says,
all right man,
I'm going to get out of here.
And then the guy just starts talking
crazy shit and left and then he keeps,
he keeps harassing Josh and Josh is
like,
okay Bro,
like I don't get why you're coming at me
but you want to come to the gym,
sign the waiver,
we can go at it.
And so josh,
by the way,
way bigger than this,
way bigger,
way bigger.
I think he's got some issues in the Josh
for like 55,
fight 70 to 75,
72 towards the end to 20 at least.
Right.
Big enormous dude and he comes in and I
guess Josh like sparked a little bit but
he's Kinda like conserving and he's
like,
because I figured this guy was going to
come in and he said he came in and then
he's like let's go.
And then they,
they,
they laced up and then they fought and
then josh is kind of just walk forward.
Just kept his hands up,
let the guy kind of bomb and get tired
and eventually took them down and
started putting it on him.
He beat the shit out of him but it
didn't.
The guy had boxing gloves on when
there's something because he's on the
smaller bought and he,
the guy chose the boxing so he chose
what he wanted to do.
So it was like an old school ufc event.
Like it was like going down and the guy
was like,
they weren't someone.
Wasn't someone trying to press charges
on Josh?
No,
no weirdness going on because it was all
over the internet and everybody was
talking about the what near did was kind
of fucked up and I'm like,
well,
I don't know man,
when a guy comes to your gym and wants
to fight like that,
that's a weird predicament for a
professional fighter to be in.
But it's real common.
Like Dojo wars have always been common.
Diaz was in them.
I mean that,
that's how they say the gracies back in
the day,
they would,
uh,
these boxers and a weight lifters.
I mean,
there's a lot of old school videos of
guys would just come in like,
you think you're the man with his
Jujitsu stuff.
Like,
let's see it.
Then they would get beat up and tapped
out,
you know?
And then that they had a respect for it.
That happens in all sorts of martial
arts schools that happened in my
taekwondo school all the time.
Once or twice a year,
some guy would come in out of nowhere
that wanted to fight and then they would
put him in there with a black belt and
you'd get kicked in the head.
It was,
it was common,
it was super cool.
It's like,
I think that's always going to be the
case if you have a place that teaches
people how to fight,
there's always getting me some fucking
Wackadoo who thinks he knows how to
fight,
wants to go in there.
And the street guys who get out,
I don't get it.
And I seen dominant cruise on a video
not that long ago.
Uh,
an old school video.
When I saw that dog,
he comes in and then he's like,
no,
just stand with me and this and that.
Did you ever see that video?
There's a video of a Dojo war where this
karate guys beat this homeless guy,
like almost to death.
And the word was that they beat him to
death,
but they dragged the guy out and threw
them in a dumpster.
But this is a.
see,
I don't know if anybody ever
definitively,
because this was something that took
place in the 19 eighties and I don't
know if they ever.
It's a fucking very disturbing video to
watch because the guy like he was
getting his ass kicked and the guy kept
beating them up.
This is it.
Yeah.
So I think the guy who's the homeless
guy who's a.
is he wearing the bell bottoms right
there?
Yeah.
That dude,
that dude see it says right there
mentally challenged,
man.
Beaten to death by MMA fighter.
See was an mma because there wasn't even
mma back then.
So the,
the,
the guy behind him,
the black guy with the black belt in the
white guy is the guy beat,
beat the fuck out of him.
And this guy,
I guess he was just a crazy person and
these guys exist that pretended he knew
martial arts and I think he thought he
was just going to go in there and work
out or something.
And so he's like throwing these little.
He's got like a little something
throwing some kicks,
but look,
he's not,
it's not even like he's really trying to
hit them.
It seems.
It's weird.
He's kind of crazy.
But the other guy is like taking his
time and he winds up beating the fuck
out of
inside,
inside like it.
So I don't know what style of karate it
is,
but this is super old school.
I mean the,
the video is shitty as fuck.
See?
But yeah,
but he's throwing the other guys throne,
but he's like two and like karate,
like,
oh,
let me try to,
we'll kick to the leg,
sweep the look.
It's weird,
man.
It's weird because it's not,
oh,
CEO,
you just connect it to the guy just
doesn't really know how to fight.
But he sort of knows how to look like
he's fighting.
He just crushed to keep pounding.
He's,
he beats the fuck out of this guy.
It's way worse than this.
Oh,
he had kicks others.
The Nita down opponent is that black
dynamite.
And he's like,
I'm done.
He's like,
nope.
So then he comes back.
It's almost,
see now he's almost kind of like
fighting for his life.
But he's fighting a guy that's a trained
martial artists that's probably been
doing this forever because he's a black
belt.
He should've just kinda knocked him and
let it.
Let it be done.
Yeah.
He's.
Oh,
they got sound effects.
It's unnecessarily there.
He's out.
Dude.
In the back of my head.
It was done here.
That though.
So he stomps his head.
Stop Dude.
Dragging them out the back door.
Yeah.
Damn,
that's crazy.
Look at the blood blood coming out of
his head.
That guy ever getting in trouble for
that.
I don't know.
I don't know what the story is behind
that
is the trail of the conflict.
This is.
This is snapchat today where you're
snitching on yourself right here.
Basically.
Evidence.
This is the blood.
My dojo.
Wow Man.
That's Kinda messed up.
Nineteen 84.
That goes.
He told the date,
seven trying to get a judge.
I mean snapchat.
I guess you could kind of make the
argument that it was a fight.
So what happened?
They show where they put the guy this
outside.
It is just blood on the ground.
The guy to die or no,
he didn't.
No,
I don't know because I don't.
I don't know if anybody's ever.
We'll see.
See if you can find out whatever data is
on it.
That's my point is like those kinds of
things they've,
they've happened throughout the history
of martial arts schools.
I saw a bunch of Dojo wars back in my
taekwondo days,
but I never saw anybody get beaten to
death like that or if the guy was,
but he could have easily died.
He got stomped on the head twice while
he was unconscious and that was a big
guy that stomped him and he stomped him
on the temple.
He could die.
He was knocked out with,
uh,
the knees on the ground and then he was
just like trying to get out,
but you can just clear as day the guy's
out of his,
which he's Naeem in the back of the head
a couple Sundays.
That's.
Well the stomps to was his head was flat
completely on the ground.
That guy just stomped his head.
Yeah.
Are.
And it's a guy,
obviously a karate guy who knows how to
kick and he stopping you.
That's not like
a regular person stomping you guys
getting to get some force behind those
stumps.
Yeah,
I don't know what happened.
See what,
find out.
Sorry to be a mood breaker.
What's next for you?
What's going on?
We want the big fights.
Me and they haven't even though you
know,
but I know.
I know Max Holloway's in front of me and
the guys who are in front of you right
now.
You're in the mix coming off last.
Yeah.
What?
What's,
what are they?
I don't like the rankings,
man.
I don't want.
I just want to fight,
man.
I've been,
I've been dude.
I'm the type of guy that I just go up.
Sean Shelby sees me and he looks at me
and then he just runs the other way.
What are the rankings?
I think I'm number like seven,
but like Dennis Bermudez number six.
I think he's in front of me.
How's that work?
Here's a.
that's a perfect example.
I don't pay attention to that man.
Honestly,
I've been fighting everybody in the 55
and 45 division.
It's like,
well,
the rankings are based on per employee,
but it's not,
it's,
it's the input output of writers.
You know,
like here's a perfect example.
When conor mcgregor knocked out Josie,
although some Brazilian writer put him
lower on the list than he was before,
he's just jealous.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot another other than
shit.
Like here's a perfect example.
When you buy a hall,
knocked out Gig Arpu,
saucy.
He was ranked below him after the fight
below him on the fucking rankings.
Well,
what are the.
What the fuck is the point of the
rankings?
If you fight a guy,
you knock him out,
you stop him.
He jumped,
spinning back,
kicked him in the head and then put them
away.
What the fuck?
What more does a guy have to do to get
ranked ahead of a guy you don't like?
I guess their ideas that most Sasaki has
more experience.
Like if you watch uriah hall fight,
you can't tell.
He's a motherfucker.
Yeah.
He's a beast.
Then stop.
Stop watching fights.
Stopped commenting.
Stopped,
stopped writing shit.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
He want,
he wanted.
He moves ahead.
That's it.
Yep.
I believe that two men.
The fuck is Dennis Bermudez ahead of
you.
I don't know.
I think because maybe he beat me.
He beat Max and then I lost a Max,
which is,
uh,
when did he beat Max Holloway?
Yeah.
He'd be Holloway Holloway couple of
years ago before conor did.
Yeah.
Bermudez is a beast dude,
but he was very good.
Very good.
No doubt about it.
I'm not saying we're the best.
Scott says anything wrong with Bermuda.
He's an awesome fighter,
but I did not know that he beat
Holloway.
I thought Halloween's only last was to
uh,
connor caught her in a dentist's last
year.
Will.
Well,
Alto Holloway's really young,
you know,
I mean,
you think when he fought Dennis,
I didn't even know he fought down,
so I'm trying to remember that.
But when he was,
your honor,
he was really young too.
I mean,
he's a young kid.
Yeah.
He used to train with that guy back and
forth.
So it's kind of weird fighting him and
that's why maybe the fight with distant
play.
He knew I had the power and then he just
kind of played the,
just moving around game and it was just
weird,
man.
I really couldn't get into a,
uh,
my style of fighting my rhythm and it
was just kinda like,
he's clever.
Yeah.
And you,
he moves a lot.
Yeah,
he's clever and not being there for the
big shots.
He rarely gets hit with big shot mixes.
Good with switch stances and everything.
But just overall we never really gotten
into a fight.
I felt like we just really didn't get
it.
Getting that type of engagement and it
was just weird because I,
I trained with this guy before,
I like I knew who he was and like I'm in
there and things are going so slow that
I know exactly everything's going on.
I really just couldn't be in the moment.
I'm Kinda like,
man,
like I know everything.
Like I'm seeing people in the front row.
I just,
I just felt really weird.
Oh Wow.
So like you weren't zoned in.
Yeah,
just didn't have the,
like the focus.
I don't know,
maybe it was just handled a little
little tattoos had I'm in the zone or
something.
I don't know if that was just a weird
smart for him.
Man.
He's a very clever guy.
I liked the way he fights.
I liked the way fuck cups wants and I
was super impressed with that because
copd is dangerous as fuck.
Yo,
that's another good one.
A way fought.
Uh,
Ricardo Lamas.
He was like,
let's just.
Yeah,
that was crazy.
Fight on my bra.
What can we do that like,
come on man.
Yeah.
Well there's certain levels of knockout
power.
Yeah.
You're a dude.
I used to,
I used to throw them around a lot,
so he,
I think he just knew that he just wasn't
going to try to engage with me and then
he just was going to stay away.
Power is a weird thing,
isn't it?
It's like some guys like,
you just have certain.
Yeah,
there's just no getting around that.
There's like,
there's certain guys that no matter what
they do,
they'll have great technique.
They'll win fights,
they'll even knock guys out,
but they'll never be able to just step
in and rumble.
Johnson somebody.
Yeah.
Savage,
you know,
that's just what makes rumble Johnson
him.
And that's what makes him,
me and Robbie lawler reprise three in
the same.
And I don't try to be a movement guy,
don't try to do this and that.
I like to be in the fight getting after
it because I feel like I can break
people that are.
I'm a knock you out.
If not,
I'm going to be in shape to go all the
rounds.
Do you ever think that maybe if you
could be a movement guy and could do all
those other things,
you could have that as well because it's
not like your power is ever going to go
away.
You're always going to have that.
Like when you knocked out dos Anjos with
that upper cut,
like that's,
that's classic Jeremy Stevens,
you know when you knocked out Bermuda's
with that flying knee,
you've got that power.
Like if you incorporate it,
all those other techniques that you see
these other guys doing as well.
Like you know,
if you ever thought of that,
like maybe just expanding what you do.
And,
and also I work on that too because
people expect a certain kind of fight
from you because you're so aggressive.
You so you know,
moving forward all the time that if you
fought in a different way it would
probably fuck people up.
Yeah,
I mean I'm always trying to work on
everything because I feel like you have
to be adapted using the Charles Darwin
theory.
It's not the strongest or the smartest
person who's willing to adapt to change.
That's going to be around the longest.
And uh,
you got so many young talented kids
coming up,
uh,
you know,
like,
just young,
you know,
like little Max Holloway's Yair,
like these little,
uh,
pedis pedis bro.
And I mean,
you got this talent.
You have to constantly be evolving,
getting better work on your game and all
angles.
Jujitsu,
wrestling who is fighting is fighting
someone good because Sarah's.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
Was a little barn barn.
I like this era.
He's a funny dude.
See that fight going like,
uh,
that uh,
that Tony Ferguson and that other guy,
see if that fight funky fight action
going on.
Craziness.
Role.
Legit fight.
Rodriguez is no fucking joke.
That's what I'm saying.
You got to be kicks.
Got To be on your toes.
Damn that dude.
Throw some wild his end to Andrew Philly
fight.
Oh,
caught him with that fucking flying
roundhouse.
Kick the damn.
He's good.
Yeah.
He's also like,
he,
he practices that shit so often.
Like you ever see him hit pads?
These karate taekwondo?
Yeah.
He'll throw like all that spinning shit
in practice all the time.
Like it's a part of his normal comments
first.
First Nature.
Not just trying to do that shit or try
to try not to be or try to be exciting
or something like that.
Just kind of harnesses his own.
What did you think of Aldo versus edgar?
This the second fight was boring dude.
Do you think it was boring?
It was boring.
I think as as a,
as a fighter,
there was a lot of stuff going on as at
a high level and a good stuff going on,
but I just thought it was boring.
I just felt like Aldo just fought to
just get by and when man,
but I'll do.
Or Frankie didn't look like himself.
Man.
I think he got caught a bunch of times.
I think although look masterful,
I thought it was a brilliant fight.
Yeah,
I mean if you're going to fight frankie,
that's the way to fight him.
I mean he threw very little kicks,
countered with punches and movement and
I thought he looked great.
Yeah.
As far as like,
I don't mean that's what,
that's what I'm saying is as I look at
that and I'm like,
I see,
I see the type of level that that is
that,
but it's just like it was a boring
fight,
but then I also felt like it was,
it was kind of weird.
I didn't see frankie moving like he did.
It made me kind of think maybe he was
injured.
I think he just got caught.
I was thinking God,
he got his and Joe,
Joe,
Joe José's a lot,
lot bigger than him and he's had his
number and Waldo looked big in that
fight too.
Like he looked smaller for the Mcgregor
fight and I think concentrated a lot on
strength conditioning for this fight.
And he looked like although of old feel
like they all looked like the older that
knocked out Mendez in Brazil.
It'll look thick.
We'll.
So I think,
yeah,
I think maybe,
you know,
he's had issues back and forth with
making 1:45,
so maybe he's got it dialed in better.
I don't know.
I Bet I bet he did because he did look
great that fight and he did.
He did find a smart fight and I just,
I just felt like he could have finished,
finished frankie.
He felt like he could have done a little
bit more,
but then I also heard that he didn't
want to throw kicks and he only used his
left hand because he had like some
snitches telling them like that Frankie
was going to take them down off kicks,
you know,
which.
But that's obvious,
isn't it?
I mean obviously frank is going to try
to take him down off cakes because all
those got that nasty left right leg
kick.
Yeah.
No,
he's always throwing kicks.
Yeah.
I don't think he's ever really took them
down to me.
I'll be right back up.
Yeah.
You know.
Well I mean he,
he just fought a great fight.
If you want to beat Frankie.
Yeah.
I mean,
I liked it,
I enjoyed it.
I thought it was a really good fight,
but I see your point.
It wasn't like,
Gosh,
that was just stylistically that,
that doesn't really play it play out
with Frankie and in him.
I think he put me in Aldo in there or me
and mcgregor.
I think you're going to see a lot of
high level action.
We're going to be kicking and punching
each other and knew each other in the
face and it's going to be exciting,
you know,
at the same time,
but still very skilled in a
method of madness type of way.
Yeah.
How old are you now,
man?
30.
Just 30.
So when you think about your career,
do you have it mapped out like what
you're trying to accomplish and when,
when do you have an exit strategy?
Do you know when you're,
when you're going to be done prime right
now it seems like 30 to 34,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Family.
Look at Robbie lawler.
I look up to that guy a lot in the way,
the way he's Kinda handled his career
and who's to say within,
you know,
what if I go in there and the next three
or four fights on skin Kao and then it's
like,
okay,
it's like Sam Sauce,
like,
man,
maybe it's time for me to hang up,
you know?
Then then I would definitely,
if I'm getting ruined like that and
hurting myself,
I don't want to be brain dead or talking
about killing my family because I have
trauma injuries or anything like that.
So definitely not.
But I definitely want to have an exit
strategy and things that I want to do.
But as of right now,
I feel healthy.
I want,
I want to keep fighting and it's like I
said,
I'd tell Sean Shelby on my man,
keep me active,
dude.
I don't want to fight twice a year.
You know that that's,
that's rough to live off of and I just
want to keep fighting because I just
want to be right back in the mix.
Even if I had to go out of the top 10
right now because everybody else has
kind of lost.
I've already fought people where they
already got fights,
you know,
let somebody else from like the 11 or
twelfth 13th guy in the rankings who's
coming off a win,
let's me and him fight and then we can
get right back in the mix so that we can
get those Josie Connors because I want
to keep the featherweight exciting,
the featherweight division.
That's why I moved down here and I feel
like a lot more athletic,
explosive and I want those exciting
fights.
I haven't fought them guys and I feel
like those are great fights for me to go
out there and really excel.
Make some big money.
And in wind.
Yeah,
just shock the world.
Oh,
you've been killing it at featherweight
and what do you walk around at?
No.
Do you weigh right now?
I'm probably like 7,577.
I know I just ran an hour yesterday.
Yeah,
lose 30 pounds.
He gets off.
Holy Shit Dude.
You know what's funny man,
is I,
I do all this work.
I get down and then like,
you know,
they get,
they give me this time off,
I get,
I go home,
I eat a little bit of food and when I'm,
when I'm at home,
like training,
that's the worst.
Like if I'm traveling,
like I'm actually all right because I'm
not eating everything,
but when I get home and my Mexican
mamacitas right there just cooking me
all the good foods just grubbing down
and then I'm like,
all right,
cool.
You know,
and no one's.
I'm just training,
doing my thing and then,
you know.
But what kind of Diet do you follow?
Do you have any nutritionist or
anything?
Yeah,
George Lockhart fitness.
George personally is brilliant.
I've been working with.
He's the guy that doesn't get enough
credit,
you know,
he does.
He's worked with a lot of athletes in
the law,
a lot of fighters and
done a fantastic job.
He's really good in military too and he
knows what he's doing and he doesn't
charge me $10,000 a camp.
So I think he's great.
I've been working with him since
beginning.
I've preached this guy and uh,
he,
he's an amazing man.
He's,
he's really actually had him a lot in my
corner and him coming to the last fight
seen me work out and he's just like,
man,
dude,
he's like,
you're on your stuff dude.
And everything that he gives me the Diet
and I just,
I feel good man.
I feel good at further away.
So when you work with a guy like George
Lockhart,
what is like,
what's the protocol?
Has these set up your camp?
Like it's all computerized.
I can basically go into the computer
type in my weight.
Uh,
the Times that I'm training the hours
that I'm training to the intensity and
then I type in my weight.
I wake up in the morning,
weigh myself,
and then I tied that into the computer
and the computer just goes off of day to
day basics gives me,
like say if I don't have Kefir,
I can substitute for egg whites and it's
all computerized.
If I need any help or I'm like,
Hey,
I'm not doing this.
He'll,
he'll adjust a little bit of things for
me.
It's basically right there on the
computer.
Do you get blood work done where you
find your nutrient levels or find what
you need or what you need to sign?
I have,
I have a long time ago and I haven't
done that recently,
but uh,
you know,
it's nutritionists like George Lockhart.
I feel great.
I,
I honestly,
I feel amazing when,
when I'm feeling good and I'm in that
right mindset and training hard,
I,
I feel good.
But no,
I haven't gotten the bloodwork done in
awhile,
but I did do that.
So it's interesting.
It's all computerized.
So the,
you,
you write your weight,
you type your weight in and you type
like what you're saying if you've got a
strength and conditioning day and he
adjusts your caloric intake accordingly.
Calorie intake,
you know,
depends on the program.
He has it all program.
Wow.
I'm not for sure the exact details how
he does that,
that's his thing and why he makes his
money.
But.
So does it show you immediately or do
you send him the information?
Then he sends it back to you
immediately.
I just click it in and then it shows you
showed me right there and then,
uh,
then like by like Saturday or Sunday,
it just for like the work week so they
can see how much,
how much I'm losing if I need to,
uh,
lower the calorie intake or if like
maybe like I'm feeling kind of lethargic
and my weight's good.
Heal up a little bit of carbs for me,
you know,
if I call him like,
hey man,
you know,
I've been doing good.
I've been killing to speak,
but you know,
I'm just,
uh,
my weights down.
He's like,
oh,
it's good.
Okay,
let's,
let's get a little bit more,
a half of a sweet potato or a little bit
more oatmeal before practice or
something like that.
So he's a,
he's very smart man.
He's very real calculated in his
approach and it's,
uh,
it's interesting to learn from in the
nutrition and everything that I get all
natural on that stuff or just
background.
He's a military guy.
He actually used to be a,
he's.
He told me that he was actually a
chunkier kid growing up and then he just
got into diet and nutrition and losing
weight and then he got into the military
and helping out the military with a
nutrition.
That's interesting that he's devised a
computer program.
I haven't heard of anybody else that
does that where you can enter in all the
data and it gives you instant results.
Yeah.
Check that out.
That is it.
That's very interesting.
I'm,
I to check out his stuff.
I'm going
to,
I'm going to go look at this after that.
Fitness vt.com.
And uh,
I've been trying to get people on this a
long time ago.
I'm just like,
man,
it's simple.
It's easy to sign.
Stand for.
I'm not for sure.
Fitness vet,
I'm not sure what the.
Okay.
Um,
so when you,
uh,
when you work with him,
so like say if you start now and you're
177 pounds,
how much time do you need to get down to
1:45.
And what do you way before you start the
big cut,
before you dehydrate yourself?
Uh,
I would only need nine weeks,
nine,
10 weeks and I'll be ready to go.
And then,
you know,
the,
the thing with now without the ivs is
I've been putting in a lot of roadwork,
you know,
uh,
on top of things.
I've just been putting in an extra
credit.
The roadwork,
the,
that runs the swims,
the cycling,
uh,
you know,
I'm into all that now as far as pushing
cardio phase a pace.
But,
you know,
a lot of people just,
they work out,
they work out and then they just do
these drastic weight cuts.
And I used to do these and uh,
you know,
I'd still feel fine,
but I was cutting so much weight man and
it,
it really started to hurt.
I mean I'm laying on my death bed and it
was like a nasty baptism and uh,
and it now,
now you know,
with the,
with these runs and burning fats,
I've learned how to stay smart and,
and learn like,
okay,
now you need three weeks hard.
And then like a week of recovery,
like on runs and,
and running,
like after say say we do like 75 minutes
of just straight wrestling and then
I'll,
I'll go run another 45 to an hour just
at a real low pace that I'm just burning
fat burning calories and like throughout
the week I'm burning like a,
like a pound and a half to two pounds
per week just depending on my body fat.
And as slowly I get down,
I just keep niching niche and niching
and then come time to double the weight.
Cut.
I'm only,
I'm only cutting,
you know,
12 pounds.
You know,
granted I've cut a lot over the time but
I've burned a lot of body fat and then
at that point your body starts to just
rejuvenate and you're recovering,
you're burning more than you're eating.
And then I'm dropping,
dropping weight.
It makes the weight cut a lot easier
than once I do the water loads and,
and more towards the way cut.
It's just that much easier and it's a
lot easier going in.
We not like,
man,
I got to cut another 15 pounds.
I'm already fucking die into socks.
Doing well.
I'm looking at a guy like you,
you know,
if I,
if I didn't know any better,
like if I wasn't involved in the sport.
Um,
and I saw a guy like you,
that's one 77 and 71 75 wherever you're
at.
And I,
and someone said you're going to fight
at 1:45.
I'd be like,
what?
Like you're not,
he doesn't have any fat to lose.
Like I'm looking at you like you don't
have,
you're not fat at all.
It had one 75.
I've always been solid.
I've never been like a real fluffed up
or anything or you know,
I've always just been like one of those
solid guys.
I've never been.
You never seen me get tossed around or
anything like that.
It just always just been solid.
Well that's why it's crazy to think that
you could even get down to 1:45.
I don't,
I don't really lift a lot of weights.
I do.
I do a lot of more footwork explosions
with medicine balls and kettle bells
and,
and a lot of sprints.
Focus,
cardio cardio's king man,
it really is right and it helps your
mental out a lot and helps cuts a lot
easier.
A lot of people don't do that.
They just train,
train,
train killed himself,
excuse me,
and then they go to cut all that weight
and they don't understand that cardio
help your,
your,
your mental state.
The runs and the weight cuts.
Yeah,
just like,
ah,
I don't know man.
You just go through breakthroughs like
when you don't want to run and it's like
you're tired after 75 minutes and you're
like,
man,
fuck dude,
I got to do this run.
But then when you do it and then you're
like,
man,
I'm going to do it like you got 20 more
minutes and you just like 20 more
minutes and I okay,
I'm going to pick up the pace a little
bit or I'm gonna keep going through.
Sometimes you'll just kind of get ran
down,
ran down and then like all of a sudden
you'll hit that,
that final runner or next run and then
boom,
you have a breakthrough.
Next thing you know,
next week you're recovering a little bit
faster.
He noticed that the fresh guys that are
coming in,
they're getting more tired than you and
just one round and you started having
these little mental breakthroughs in
these little psychological steps.
You ever read the art of war.
It's just like little little moves like
that that you can kind of see that are,
that are that are approaching your game
and it's just the psychological effect
that like,
hey man,
I've,
I've done this cardio and then I ran for
this amount.
I mean the last,
the last camp I ran to Brazil and back.
Basically it's how much I ran.
So I was like,
dude,
there's no way that this guy is going to
push a pace that I can't handle,
you know,
and it's just these mental breakthroughs
that the runs really help.
That's interesting.
So you,
what kind of strength and conditioning,
like what kind of cardio do you do
outside of running sprints?
Sprint.
Lot of sprints running to.
You heard like dominick Cruz.
I mean that guy just moves,
moves,
moves in,
yes.
Sprints.
This is part of running and then,
um,
you know,
strength to strength,
conditioning,
mixing in sprints with a lot of
explosive movements,
a lot of footwork,
lot of the dam.
Again,
Nadia Aguilar does just.
Yep.
I mean,
I worked with George Castro now at
alliance him in May.
He's,
uh,
he's been with me for awhile and he's
the guy that really,
he's like my big brother when I don't
want to do shit.
And he's like,
no,
like,
we're going to get this done.
He's that little voice that's like,
yeah,
you can,
but it's real voice.
He's that dude who can train,
like turn it all the way up.
Somebody I can really push me,
you know,
some guys are just like,
if this guy was over and,
you know,
no offense if he's like yelling at me,
like,
do these brands that like,
come on Bro.
But we've seen George Castro looked him
right in the eye.
Yeah,
he's offended.
And uh,
you know,
George counties,
just that guy.
He's like,
my big brother.
he's like,
Hey,
let's get to know them really well.
You want to win?
He's like,
do you want to win?
Like,
yeah,
and he,
he just,
he,
I connect with him mentally.
It's like I can,
I can,
I can feel bro.
He was like,
he's got a big heart.
He cares.
He genuinely just really pushing you to
the top.
And Man,
we've been dominant legalese.
And so when you're doing a,
you're doing sprints and what are the
kinds of things you're doing?
Like conditioning wise?
We hit the track.
We had the track usually about every
Saturday.
Uh,
you know,
we're,
we're doing a lot of lateral drills.
We're doing 100 yard sprints were we're
running around the full track sprint,
so a lot of his legs,
legs,
cardio,
cardio is king.
A lot,
a lot of running.
Do you do the Airdyne you're doing
anything with your arms to the
aerodynamics.
We do,
you know,
lateral drills,
explosive medicine balls,
throws kettlebells.
What does that,
uh,
the
wheel with your hands that you do that's
like a bike with your hands.
A lot of guys do.
Do you do that thing?
And I'm talking about
think I'm talking about Broccolis or had
that thing I'd never done that.
Use the old school speed bag.
Is that what you do that are just
getting my uh,
Miguel raise my boxing coach.
Dude,
he'll,
he'll have you throw in like 5,000
punches and around you know that.
That guy's the man.
He's Mexican style.
He's from Tijuana school.
Thai boxer.
Yeah.
What?
It's funny how many fucking bad ass
fighters came out of Mexico.
It's kind of crazy when you really stop
and think about it.
Like they live in a different world,
man.
You're talking about drug lords.
If you go down to their,
in their gym and is the price shoot you
like,
Hey,
I want to challenge you.
See Ya.
And Ain't nobody going to care or
mentioned the damn thing or put it on
camera.
Know.
So I mean that's a different world they
live in another.
Do you monitor your heart rate?
Yup.
I sure do.
Yep.
I do the vo two Max and,
and all that.
And uh,
I know what zones to kind of stay in
when I'm like,
just kind of slowly doing my runs.
But then at the same time you can't be a
pussy and manage your heartbeat.
You got to fucking get after it.
You know,
you gotta you gotta break yourself,
Dude.
I mean there are so many times that I
wanted to quit and that I just felt like
crying and it was just done.
I pushed myself.
But then boom,
I had those mental breakthroughs.
Like,
you know what,
I fucking finished.
You did.
I did it.
Most people went home after,
after wrestling.
I mean there's times where I find myself
in the gym still running on the
treadmill or running at the beach and no
one's around,
no one I'll,
I'll hit up.
Some of my friends were like,
oh no,
no,
you know,
I'll have like one guy come in and run
with me a few times.
But sometimes I find myself alone or my
strength conditioning coach will put us
through a workout.
And then I'll go run like another 45
slash 75 or an hour and a half.
And I'll look to my left,
looked to my right and no one's there,
just like my coach and I'll be like,
where are they at,
George,
where the,
I like the Diaz,
you know,
because his name is George George.
And he's like,
that's why you're fucking savages you,
that's why you're going to win.
And that's really what it comes down to.
But as far as the heart rate,
I get it.
I do it.
I followed that program.
But then there's also a time to kill
yourself on sprints,
you know,
not,
not like spar,
spar all the time.
I barely spar at all.
I spar probably once a week right now I
haven't,
I haven't since my fight I've,
I've done tai drills and drilling and
wrestling and strength conditioning.
I've already been doing sprints and
running.
I just ran an hour easily yesterday and
uh,
I just don't spar,
spar,
preserve me.
You can only get hit so many times
already.
I already know a fight,
but you know,
when it comes time to an camp,
you know,
I,
I do my sparring or you know,
uh,
probably by Friday I'll spar two rounds,
take around,
off spar,
around,
be done.
Alliance is one of the best gyms in the
world.
And Eric del Fierro doesn't get enough
credit.
He's one of those guys.
He's a quiet guy,
doesn't need a lot of attention.
I always put him in a category like Mark
Henry's,
another one of those guys,
doesn't get enough credit,
just sort of like lays back is not like
one of those guys that puts a lot of the
spotlight on himself.
But he's done a phenomenal that Jim is
amazing.
So many great fighters come out of there
as well.
We actually got dorms now,
so these young Mexican fighters and
people from all over are starting to
come into the,
uh,
come into the gym.
We have these little,
uh,
dorms right next to the gym that,
that are open now that are available.
Uh,
we got dominick Cruz just won the title.
You got me when you got Phil Davis when
and he's about to fight for a title
Justin Lawrence's back.
Uh,
I mean Ross Pearson's there.
I mean he,
he's fighting a Jorge Mazda at all
coming up.
So,
uh,
all these guys were putting on good
windstream Pearson's fight.
Is He fighting one 70?
Yeah,
I think so.
Ross is moving to one 70?
No,
I think dollars.
$70 go down to 55 again.
No,
he's fine at one 70.
Oh yeah,
because he just had that close fight
with or you know,
I think it would maybe last the first or
two rounds and then at the end,
you know,
Ross has putting it on him.
I guess he just hit up.
Joe was like,
Hey,
I heard,
oh boy.
Backed out.
I'm,
I'm ready to go.
Awaits.
Good.
And just.
Yeah,
because Ross was fighting at 45 for a
little bit.
Tried 45.
God Damn.
He was skinny.
He didn't like that.
Yeah.
He doesn't like that at all.
He's cutting a lot of weight and I don't
know if he was doing it properly or
whatnot,
but he just didn't like it and he likes
finding 55.
Ross likes to lift and he's a big dude.
He's got some big legs on him.
He's a power guy and uh,
you know,
45 stuff,
dude.
Yeah,
I would imagine it's a takes everything
I got,
but I kinda liked putting into that
point where it's,
it's,
it's breaking the edge,
you know,
because there's a point where like,
I'm nice,
I,
I'm,
I'm fine,
you know,
like fight the whole way in thing.
We'll get into that a little bit later
about how you can weigh in early and
then you eat.
I kind of liked that edge where I feel
like I'm dying and then like I looked
that guy in the eye who's,
you know,
I think about who he could beat me or
this and that,
you know,
I'm training from the whole camp and I
kind of liked that,
that,
that edge,
that switch of that,
that meanness.
It's on motherfucker.
Like I've been trained in long time.
You know,
I've,
I've put everything into this and it
really takes all,
I got to make 45,
so I kinda like this which for me and
some people may be different.
Do you like the fact that you know,
that he's got to go through that as
well?
So I like the fact that I have to,
it takes everything I have in all the
discipline and all hard training to make
145 pounds and once I'm there,
I mean I feel ferocious.
I feel mentally strong and it takes
everything I got and I like doing that
because I'm going to be at my best and
I'm going to perform at my best when
it's like that,
it's a good mental switch for me to
have.
I like that.
That's my style.
That's interesting.
You know,
conor Mcgregor's coach was talking about
that he thinks that connor not cutting
weight was probably a bad thing for them
and that,
you know,
fighting Diaz and just being able to eat
whatever he wanted.
It not go through the grueling pattern
that he's gone through all his other
fights.
Look at his demeanor though,
at the winds were at 45.
He looks like a savage.
I mean he looks like death,
like,
like we all do,
but he looks like he's like,
you know what,
I'm ready.
I'm ready to get after it.
He's,
he looks mean.
When he came in and fought Diaz,
he's smiling and he's all happy.
Just like,
oh Bonnie fast.
See his demeanor.
He was like,
oh,
nothing's going on.
It's like,
okay,
now these guys that are weighing in,
does that,
that,
does that take away a little bit of the
intensity,
you know,
it was kind of asking dominic that
little bit and he's just like,
Nah,
it's still going to get after it,
you know,
because I was like,
man,
if I go back and already you just stay,
can I come in?
Like,
am I going to be that intense at the,
at the,
do you mean what you're saying is um,
because there's new way in rules where
you can weigh in way earlier.
So,
um,
when they announced the weigh ins now,
like say if the fighters weigh in at
4:00,
you've already weighed in,
you wait in 10:00 in the morning,
so you've already had a chance to
rehydrate,
get some food,
and then you get back on.
The good thing is everybody looks way
healthier when they weigh in because
man,
some like connor's perfect example.
Some guys would.
Wayne,
James Irvin was probably the worst ever.
James Irvin,
when you would fight at one 85,
like Jesus Christ,
you see him,
he was so drunk and Oh my God,
man,
he was so drained.
He looked,
he looked crazy.
It looked like he was about to die.
First Time I made 45.
I remember seeing you and Dana and you
like Dana was a,
you're right.
Yeah.
And that was ivy days,
right?
Yeah.
How much of a difference is it using the
Nivea and not using an IV?
And I don't really feel a difference to
be honest.
Really.
I mean,
George Lockhart,
you may be changing that for me because
of the nutrition that he,
that he,
he's there,
his whole teams,
they're just feed me coming in and
knocking on my,
my hotel room and like,
eat this,
do this at this time,
and it just makes it easier.
And then,
uh,
you know,
they rehydrate me properly and I,
and I believe in those guys in my team
and the rehydration and I feel the same.
If not,
I feel better.
So That's interesting.
You feel better?
Hmm.
Yeah.
Some guys have said that,
like Joe Silva was actually telling me
that it's actually more effective to do
it orally,
orally.
A lot of doctors
trusted,
uh,
one of my doctors,
a Brad Arches back home said that,
uh,
he gave me a lot of tips because when
this came in I'm like,
I'm freaking out.
I'm like,
fuck dude,
they're taken with these ivs.
I'm gonna.
Have to go back 55.
No freaking out,
you know?
And they were sending me all this stuff,
you know,
and I,
I read a lot about it because I was
like,
all right,
well do this.
And then I met Daryl Christian,
one of my wrestling coaches who's a
WHO's a phenom Olympian,
and uh,
he's just like,
we got to put in this robot dude.
He's like,
we've got to start building your cardio
base.
He's like,
you've always just killed yourself,
killed yourself.
And then had a kid yourself making
weight.
He's like,
you never build a cardio base.
He never had a solid foundation.
So then we started these heart rate
monitors,
vo twos and put in these broad programs,
putting these different sprints.
But you were always in good shape.
Like,
what do you mean by you didn't have a
cardio base?
Uh,
I was more or less to sprint.
It was just top heavy.
I never really had a low intensity.
And uh,
what is it like the vo two Max?
The reason why people do that is because
a lot of people wanted to know how they
would build endurance.
And people think that you just need to
sprint,
and you're gonna be in good shape.
Granted,
you might be in good shape,
but none of them had a low base cardio
where they would just run that like say
like a four point eight or five point.
Oh,
on a treadmill for a long period of
time.
And actually how you build the anaerobic
system a lot better is through low base
cardio.
It's done based system or is it
aerobics?
Aerobics,
aerobics system is exploding.
Yeah,
they'll,
they find that you can expand recovery
and,
and uh,
work harder and a lactic threshold by
doing the low base cardio like Diaz
does.
Yeah.
It's just constant pressure because you
got that guy who's going to sprint and
he's gonna head out and then like he's
going to drop down in,
in,
in that round.
And the guy might be here,
but then he's going to sprint.
But then he just,
he just can't.
He just gonna slowly start to pull in.
That's how diaz he slowly just kind of
just passes you.
The guy may sprint and be punching a
punching him.
And he just sticks pow,
POW,
POW.
Yeah,
well Diaz is hitting you with 50 percent
punches,
but he's hitting you with 30 times more
constants and then in the round he's
able to recover even better while you're
already at lactic threshold.
Then you try to,
you try to fire up the heart rate again.
It's like dude,
your body's like managed to shot and
they found out through those video and
those runs that the aerobic base is
built more through low base cardio and
that's what he's talking about building
the base because you can't slow pace
cardio low,
low,
low pace and that you can't just build a
house without a base.
Need that base.
And that's what I really started
learning and honestly I feel a lot more
efficient.
I feel a lot more healthier and in my
cardio even a lot better in the fights I
believe.
That's interesting.
So the long runs and the long cardio,
it sort of like a,
a solid foundation and then sprints on
top of that explosion on top of that.
Got To do it all.
Do you follow like a Tabata protocol or
anything like that?
Do you know what that is?
Wouldn't know was to butter Tabata is a,
an endurance protocol that uh,
I don't know why,
why it's called Tabata,
but I believe it's like a 22nd sprints
followed by 10 seconds of rest,
20 seconds sprints.
There's,
there's some sort of.
My friend John Rollo told me about it
and a lot of athletes apparently follow
it.
Here it is.
What is Tabata Tabata training is the
most popular one of the most popular
forms of high intensity interval
training consists of eight rounds of
ultra high intensity exercises in a
specific 20 seconds on 10 seconds off
interval.
Yup.
So when it says eight rounds,
so I guess eight,
22nd sprints and eight ten second rests.
So
I do a little bit of Tabata training for
sure.
I mean we even go even doing 30 seconds,
45 seconds and then you know,
eventually it peaks off in itself,
but for sure 100 percent and be be doing
that as well.
And then low based training.
That's it.
Interesting that you're a big proponent
of that long slow style because that was
one of the things that some people that
weren't fighters,
but we're a strength and conditioning
people would say that that's not going
to benefit you,
you know,
they would say that's not what you need
to do in a fight because a fight is
explosion.
It's fast and you don't have that slow
running thing.
But old school,
like old school boxers,
they all ran like that.
They all ran long miles.
Yeah.
And they ran
slower.
Do you ever see Mike Tyson in his early
days?
Just slowly running for him?
Yeah,
he was running five miles,
five miles.
You could probably get done within low,
low pace,
you know,
35,
45 minutes.
You know,
it's Kinda interesting because my
strength conditioning coach now,
George Castro,
he used to workout with Don Frye and
he'd be like,
man,
one day I was stretching into the like,
well what the fuck you do get,
get gloves on,
get in the ring.
And he was like,
take off your shirt,
let's do this,
you know?
And then like they just go,
but there was no,
there was no structure to it.
But now you know,
we're,
we're meeting these coaches and the,
the,
the scientists and behind it,
you know,
and,
and uh,
you know,
my only a Olympian coach,
Darrell Christian,
he's just like,
dude,
he's like,
you cannot build high based cardio,
bike sprints,
press print,
killing herself.
He's like,
we got to build this low base and he's
also a spinal surgeon,
you know,
and he's also been in the game for a
long time and he's like,
that's how all these fighters and top
notch guys would stay in shape all year
round.
It was drilling,
drilling,
and he was like,
we would just do long runs anytime we
get a break.
We had to be doing long runs like every
other day.
And he's like,
that's why we were able to make weight,
stay on task and be in shape all the
time.
And he's to make sense man.
And it really makes sense when you talk
about the Diaz brothers,
you know,
as I was saying,
Diaz,
but really both the Diaz brothers.
But nate is a little different than NEC
has.
Nate will explode more than nick.
Nate has a little more fire power when
he goes after dudes,
but both those guys are known for doing
triathlons and you know,
nick even more so than,
and you know what they smoke weed to do
and then they and then they go out and
then they'll just run forever and that's
okay.
You're just building that base,
building that car to you and they,
they just,
they had those mental breakthroughs.
Like,
dude,
I ran three hours after practice.
Like what the fuck are you going to do
to me?
I'm going to keep pacing on you and
you'll see it.
I,
I can break people in the gym by
constant pressure pace and then like I
can recover within 20,
30 seconds.
Why?
They're like,
right.
You know,
and their,
their bodies is breaking down and it
truly does work.
And it's just a simple science.
Isn't it funny because the glamor stuff
is explosions,
right?
The glamor stuff is cleans and snatches.
Throwing fucking tires around a parking
lot and sledge hammer in a tire on it.
Kettle bells that look like they're 10
pounds that weigh like 101.
If you ever done the uh,
Keith Weber Kettle Bell Co,
extreme kettlebell cardio workout.
No Dude,
this is another fucking.
Yeah.
What's crazy about it is it's 40.
He'll you do it with a 35 pound bell and
you're like bitch ass 35 pound
Kettlebell with flex.
I going to do it seems like nothing.
It's not like glamorous because it's
light,
but man,
it breaks you.
It breaks you.
Yeah.
We have it.
I'll have,
I'll have on it.
Send you one man.
I think there's one too when I think he
has a three out now.
But Dan,
he's a stud.
I've had that guy in here too.
He's a fucking master when it comes to
these,
um,
these workouts and it's the same thing.
It's 45 minutes man.
And it's just breaks you down.
I do it.
And when I started out,
like for the first 20 seconds,
I'm like,
how am I even going to get tired doing
this?
Two minutes later I'm like,
oh my God,
I got 38 more minutes of this.
Yeah.
The fuck I'm going to do this.
It's the glamorous shit is like
explosions,
right?
The glamorous shit is ridiculous,
but hitting the bag,
but it's,
that's more,
it's more fun to do anyway.
Oh,
is this it?
Yeah,
this.
Oh see,
it seems like it seems like not that big
a deal,
right?
Like what are you doing?
You get this little bitch ass.
Wait,
you only doing 35 pounds but my long
periods of time doing just difficult
shit like this and just constantly
moving and squad and then yeah,
I think there's something real to
running,
man.
I think running is something.
There's something about long slow
running.
The mental,
I think it is that right
challenge.
Anybody go out on a run and don't take
your phone.
Just go out on a run where you have to
run.
Like say you run two,
two and a half miles and you don't
listen to music and you have to go back.
I do,
but a lot of people they just,
they'll run like 15 minutes and I'm
like,
they're done.
When you say don't take your phone,
what do you really try to challenge
yourself like one time?
Just because sometimes I listen to music
and sometimes I just like to listen to
my thoughts.
Like what am I thinking right now?
What are my thoughts?
What are my thoughts bringing me and uh,
it's hard to.
It's meant it's mentally you'll find
out.
It's more mentally,
uh,
than anything than the physical.
Do you get addicted to that?
Runner's high.
Yeah.
Do you know what sex is better?
Dude.
You know,
sex.
Sex is better.
Sleep dude.
Especially inclined sprints.
I just feel like your testosterone's a
little,
but yeah,
it definitely is a good sprint hollow.
Anytime you're doing like real intense
stuff,
like high intensity things like
sprinting they say is really good for
your testosterone.
Yeah.
Hill sprints in particular,
right?
Yup.
Hill sprints or inclines a treadmill's
uh,
you know,
even working with kettlebells ever hit
like a good kettlebell session.
Then we can just like,
man,
I feel freaking good.
Your testosterone's moving,
you just feel a lot more BC.
Yeah.
It's interesting how high intensity
stuff does that spikes your endocrine
system?
Yeah,
I love that.
I like to feel bad and say it's a
natural good feeling that I have.
I'm 30 years old and never injected
anything in my life and uh,
I like,
I like that high and the mental aspect
of it,
that's kind of interesting too because
people do take steroids just like man
now that,
that little,
that little edge that they got the
little high than they were getting in.
They're just like,
yeah,
I'm killing it.
But then when they stopped doing that,
mentally they get fucked dude.
Like,
dude,
like man must still the same guy.
My Body looks different.
I never really put in the work with.
He used to say that,
you know,
and then like what you think about,
like you're like,
man is there,
mental has got to be broken,
you know,
like what the hell
you ever see Dan Gable,
uh,
or hear him talking about that when he
was competing against the back
during the doping days where the
Russians,
he knew they were all on steroids,
but his philosophy was banned from the
Olympics.
They didn't actually,
they didn't change it.
They were about to get banned totally,
but they pulled back and they got a real
problem with Brazil.
Do you hear those?
Um,
those Australian people were staying in
the Olympic village like this fucking
place.
The toilets were all backed up.
His electrical wires hanging out of the
fucking walls.
It's not safe.
And it was over the Dan Gable thing
though.
Dan Gable is a fucking animal,
right?
One of the best wrestlers ever.
Dan said that when he was competing that
he felt like it didn't matter if those
guys did steroids because they didn't do
the work.
So they knew that they didn't do the
work.
So in their head,
if one thing went wrong,
they would unfold and fall apart and he
will break them.
He felt like he had a mental advantage
over guys that did steroids.
The guys that cheated,
that they were not going to be able to
beat him.
It didn't matter.
Know.
And he was right.
I mean he beat everybody.
I believe that when,
like I said,
when you're doing these runs and he's
mental breakthroughs and you're really
putting in the work and when it's all
said and done and then you're peaking
and everything kind of wears off and
everything's just flowing,
right.
It's like you just look in the mirror
and you're like,
look at that guy and you're like,
dude,
there's nothing that you can do that's
going to break me.
I've already been broken down many of
times.
It's the same thing the army does.
They break you down to build you up and
then when you're in that complete,
when you've,
when you've pushed yourself passionate
limits and you've had those mental
breakthroughs of where you thought about
quitting,
but then you kept going and then you did
it again and again and again,
and you keep pushing like your boy did
the 100 miles.
Now he's going to do 200.
You know,
just mentally he has an advantage over a
lot of people.
You get comfortable in that horrible
state.
Yeah.
Being uncomfortable.
Uncomfortable.
Yeah.
Dan gambled those.
There's a cautionary tale on that as
well because Dan Gables had two hip
replacements,
knee replacements,
like his body,
bro.
He's so tough.
He broke his body and that's uh,
that,
that is,
you know,
I've always wondered about guys like
maybe Cain Velasquez or these guys that
are constantly getting injured.
Like they're almost too tough.
Yup.
Maybe they're not training.
Right.
You know,
you've got to stay up on Rehab as much
as you're training.
Man.
I'm at home,
you know,
everybody's talking about Netflix and
chill.
When I go home I'm on a,
I'm on a Lacrosse Ball,
I'm on a foam roller,
a I got a bow staff state that I had a
tip,
you know,
getting into my neck,
like a bow staff.
And I had a,
my mean like a,
um,
like what guys like hit each other with
and I had it tipped out so that like I
can like dig into my neck,
my neck and put it into the wall.
So it has like a point at the top
because normally shaved down like a
pencil.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
Javin yourself with a fucking vampire
stake.
Yup.
Right into all my muscles that are sore
and it.
And you do it yourself.
Yeah.
Myofascial release.
Oh Wow.
And you stick it in your neck?
Yep.
Neck pecs,
subscap.
Again in my,
you know,
breaking up my abdominals,
getting into my calves,
you know,
when,
when I'm at home,
you know,
because I,
I like Rehab from,
uh,
from my therapist,
like once a week when I'm in camp,
but on the outside,
like I'm constantly maintenance in my
body,
the injuries,
you know,
when I'm throwing those bombs of right
hands and stuff.
I'm like,
man,
I'm freaking sore.
My next Jack,
my back's Jack,
you know.
Have you ever used one of these things?
Man,
this is a.
Oh yeah,
one of those.
Uh,
I go,
I got one of supernovas that's,
I liked that one,
but I like the big one even better.
The Wad supernova from a rogue fitness,
they have those.
I live by that big one man.
I like the little one,
but honestly more pinpoint the ones will
break up like the bigger areas and it's
good.
But then when she,
once you break that down,
you want to get even more pinpoint.
Yeah.
In lacrosse ball,
he didn't use you loser.
Lacrosse balls just as good and a lot of
ways that one's got a little bit more
texture to it.
So some people like that.
But you know,
this is,
this is legitimate here.
Rogue.
Yeah.
So when you broke fitness,
they got a lot of great shit man.
I got one of those.
I'm a reverse hyper machines from them
two in the back.
You ever used that reverse hyper,
hyper ice fibrates sort of?
No,
no,
no.
Reverse hypers.
Uh,
it's a,
uh,
it's a decompression machine.
Oh,
you,
uh,
you lift with it.
It's Louie Simmons from west side
barbell invented it.
And what it is,
is,
um,
you can show it right here.
It's like you,
you go,
it pulls you down,
show them in a video if you can,
you lean your body over this platform.
And then when you let the weight down,
it actually,
it's like a,
a,
and the active decompression for your
back.
That's Louie Simmons.
He's a pretty,
pretty much a legendary power lifter
guy,
but also super smart dude and so like
when she's lifting it up there,
when it's going down,
it's decompressing her spine so it's,
it's strengthening it on the up,
but on the down it's pulling it apart
and so because the distance that the
weight travels underneath you,
it asks for an active decompression of
the back.
It's phenomenal,
man.
I was having some back issues.
Nothing helped me a lot.
Yup.
Do you do any yoga or anything like
that?
I do hot yoga when I'm in camp every
Friday I like at 4:30.
I go and do a hot yoga and I do an hour
and a half and that in itself is a
mental thing.
You got to get through because I look
over.
I'm like,
damn,
it's got to be like an hour.
You how have a look over it?
We were in there 10 minutes and then I
look over.
I'm like,
man,
this old guy is doing it.
I can do it right.
Get all my girls in there.
You know,
I got to be the man saw my,
you know,
I gotta I gotTa step up and to get
through them.
Damn things.
It's intense.
I do that twice a week and I've done it,
you know,
I'm not going to lay on my back and just
focus on breathing because all my,
oh my job,
you know,
and you're already cutting weight and
got a full week of training and you're
probably dehydrated too.
I always try to drink a lot of water.
I mean I'm,
I'm drinking water constantly.
I try to get over a gallon a day.
I got to alkaline machine machine.
Yeah.
What does that shoe.
It keeps your body in higher alkaline
which your body naturally
he's got like a five or whatever they
say to be over a five or better because
you're a cancer cannot survive in a
higher alkaline,
uh,
like almost acs type stuff.
Like if your body's like broken down,
that's how you're able to get sick as if
your immune system is broken down.
Well,
this actually helps with a faster
rehydration recovery and keeps your body
in a higher alkaline state.
So it's harder to get shit done.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Jamie looked that up because I've heard
that you really can't change the
alkaline state of your body or of your
blood.
I don't know.
Things that you can do it.
Let me.
Wheat Grass keeps you in higher alkaline
and I mean I.
But,
but is it a,
your blood more alkaline?
Like what?
What is,
what is getting more alkaline?
Your blood?
Yeah.
I don't know if that's true,
but what about the honest supplement
says say that uh,
you know,
they're from higher,
a higher altitude and that they're
getting it from these grounds.
That's cordyceps.
Mushrooms,
that's different.
Cordyceps mushroom is a mushroom that
aids and oxygen utilization that doesn't
have anything to do with see what,
what people do.
Um,
there's like a lot of talk about
alkaline,
like making your blood alkaline and how
it changes.
But I remember reading something that,
that's Horseshit,
but first of all,
what you're doing is all healthy.
Like if you're telling me you'd taken
wheat grass juice,
you're getting fido nutrients,
you're getting,
you know,
all sorts of minerals that you're
getting healthy vitamins for sure.
It's definitely really good for you.
So wheat grass juice is phenomenal.
I mean,
I,
I try to eat my body and in the state
and I'm always drinking that water.
Test your blood.
I mean,
how do you know that you're in an
alkaline state?
Are you testing yourself?
Uh,
I have tested,
I've tested the water of life taking
strips and test it out,
but no,
I've never,
I haven't tested my blood to see if I
am.
The only time I've done that was with
uh,
when I took like the Piss test is a
test,
my rehydration and stuff.
The guy he lives let you look it in the
scope.
The Usada Guy,
you know,
he comes in and he's like,
Hey,
pull your pants down,
start paying.
And then he'll put it in there.
And uh,
the guy he was,
the last time I did it,
he's like,
look at the light,
see that?
And like I was,
I was pretty high and he's like,
this is good.
He's like,
that means you're really hydrated.
And he's like,
that's really good.
It's definitely good to be hydrated.
Drinking a lot of water,
especially when you're training as much
as you are.
It's very,
very,
very important.
They say that just a small percentage of
dehydration has a big impact on I fletc
performance.
Yeah.
Thirty percent.
Really a little bit dehydrated.
Wow.
A decrease it by 30 percent towing a fax
to that.
I've learned in the Fitness Vet
Lockhart,
uh,
you know,
the sumo wrestlers,
the only twice a day,
but they're eating only twice a day.
Their body conserves a lot more because
they're like,
oh,
this is the only food that we're going
to get.
And they hold onto it as competitive.
Like we eat a $45 wheat like five,
six times a day.
So our body constantly pushing it out.
Like,
oh,
we're going to get more.
We get more than with just like water,
water's like gas and where you put in,
the more you're going to burn off.
Right.
That's a,
that's a counter intuitive thing that
you hear about guys cutting weight.
They drink a ton of water before they
have to dehydrate themselves,
so your body's used to extending that
water.
It doesn't try to hold onto it.
Is that the idea behind it?
Yep.
Excuse.
It's like,
oh,
we're going to get more and more so just
it'll just keep expanding out,
push it out,
push it out.
Do you fuck around with distilled water
now?
I haven't in a long time.
I haven't heard that.
It's of dangerous.
That's not good for your body,
right?
Because your body can actually be.
It strips you of minerals because you.
Your water's supposed to be attached to
all these minerals and when you just
drinking only distilled water,
your body kind of freaks out.
Yup.
That can be dangerous.
Too much of that.
And I've heard of people kinda like
convulsing.
I think I sent somebody from the
ultimate fighter show one time,
like water load and then fell asleep and
then he was like,
you know,
that probably freaked me out a little
bit,
but what's fucked up is if you could
drink too much water,
you can die.
Yeah.
And I,
I saw our,
remember,
uh,
I was in Sacramento I think.
And there was a,
maybe a San Jose,
I don't remember if it was a local radio
show,
had a contest to drink the most water to
when a playstation.
And this lady drank so much water.
She died.
Yeah.
I was like,
I didn't know you could fucking die from
water.
Apparently.
Like frats,
like people like pledging for frats.
People have died from it to a hazing
type stuff.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's crazy.
Funny thing about alkaline.
I found a website talking about it.
I don't know if this is how legit said
per precise nutrition.com.
It just talks about the claims of
alkaline water and it really says
there's no legit studies that even said
that it'll do anything to.
You did that,
you were that you can even make it
change to an alkaline state.
Yeah.
See,
that's what I was seeing that the
variables,
the variation is so small that that it's
like you're not going to get that from
like water tested the water before.
I've never tested my own blood and I've
only seen the that I was rehydrated at
a,
at a high alkaline,
but I mean there might be some sort of
benefit to it anyway.
Even if you can't like change the actual
state of your blood.
I mean there's some sort of benefit for
it biologically.
One maybe ask George.
Maybe he would know.
He probably know more than we would.
The only thing it does say that might be
why it's his kidney.
Patients should avoid alkaline water,
which is why athletes and exercises are
one subgroup who might benefit from
drinking it.
I don't know what that statement really
means,
but it doesn't make sense.
That's the only thing really adds in
there.
Do you ever fuck around with
cryotherapy?
I've done it.
Yeah.
I really find that fund the difference.
I find more or less a mile fashion.
Having somebody digging in with like an
elbow or something,
it's a lot more beneficial.
I've done cryotherapy.
What about both?
I mean,
I don't think there's anything that you
could do for Rehab.
I mean,
I've,
I've done the float tanks and stuff like
that.
Just time to where I'd get my mind at
ease and it's pitch black.
I don't have my kids running around,
you know,
ask him for juice and take me here.
Take me there,
you know,
any of that.
So it's good.
I mean,
any type of recovery that you do.
I mean
if you're a high level athlete and
you're out there just banging on your
body,
I mean any mile Fascia,
release a cryotherapy flow,
you know,
any type of meditation floats,
phenomenal for um,
um,
magnesium too because that like epsom
salts bath,
not the floating is great because your
body absorbs magnesium but float tanks
filled with epsom salts.
You get a lot of magnesium from that,
that way.
And you're able to relax too.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Just kind of calm down.
Let me crazy way because it's like zero
gravity.
Like you feel everything sort of
stretching out and unwinding.
Yeah.
You got one of those in your house,
right?
Yeah,
my basement too.
That's awesome.
It's pretty dope.
Edibles and just getting the Zona people
come over.
They go,
what the fuck is that?
It looks like I got a big meat locker
down on with a man.
Come on in,
man.
Show you some shit.
Like,
got hookers in there.
What do you got?
Dead people.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
there's,
there's a bunch of different things that
people have shown that have some sort of
benefit and it's about finding like,
I guess what really jives with you,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean look at a guy like Dana White,
just travel all the time,
you know what I mean?
What do you,
how do you stay healthy all the time?
You know,
like traveling,
you know,
you got to take vitamins with you.
For sure.
I take probiotics as well.
That's a big thing on it.
Has this thing total gut health.
That's huge.
Yeah.
The chlorella,
chlorella or whatever.
Uh,
well total gut health is a combination
of probiotics and a,
um,
uh,
a bunch of other stuff that's in there
that,
um,
well pull,
pull it up,
pull up a on it,
total gut health so he could see what
all the different ingredients are.
But,
um,
I'm a big believer in probiotics.
I eat a lot of Kimchi.
I eat,
um,
different sorts of Sauerkraut,
organic Sauerkraut,
natural sauerkraut.
I think a fermented foods and,
and,
um,
a key for you were talking about key for
the earlier.
I drink that stuff too,
so all the different stuff that's in
there.
Um,
it's hard for me to read that.
Jamie
probiotics,
a Kombucha.
Oh yeah,
I love that Shit.
I drink that every day.
Dude.
I need a sponsorship.
The Kombucha Dude,
I spent a lot of money,
gts,
Kombucha,
Holla at Jeremy Stevens.
Acidophilus is in there.
It's also the,
um,
the good thing about these as the,
they're in little packets so you can
take them with you.
And,
uh,
the actual live culture that's in lives
off the substrate that's in the packets.
So it's a,
it's actually a little ecosystem.
And you're just,
I'll love on him.
And I live by it.
I just gave my buddy some of them in
mind and we're doing these runs the
other day and he's just like,
man,
I think getting these dreams now I can
remember my dreams.
He's like,
I'm sleeping better.
And he was like,
I feel so good.
You know,
he's always kidding.
Yeah,
I think it's calming.
And it's also a,
I think that is also a trip to fan trip
to fan which produces,
um,
uh,
it's the building block for Serotonin
trip to Fan,
which your body converts to five htp and
a five htp.
Your body converts to Serotonin.
That's big for dreams.
Yeah.
And you wake up a lot happier,
motivated.
A lot of people that are into lucid
dreaming,
they take that Shit.
They'll take like tryptophan or five htp
or Alpha brain which contains coleen.
It'll take these different nootropics
before they go to sleep and purpose so
that they could have trippy dreams.
Right.
I did that the other day.
Dude,
here's a weird thing.
I'm actually a big dreamer and I get
into these dreams and I kind of figured
out like what they're about and I had
two teeth fall out and uh,
one of them meet your,
you know,
the thing that they say is money is
coming in death and I just had my bonus
and a banged in my bank account and then
my grandma right now is at the hospice.
I just found out today actually gonna
fly out tonight to get there early in
the morning to see her and I'm like,
dude,
the two teeth,
well,
money.
And then now my grandma's sick.
So whoa dreams doing that.
That's crazy.
You ever.
You ever done James?
Because I think last time I was talking
about the show where I knew I was
flying,
I could just,
that's a common one.
Yeah.
And it's real.
It's like you're in,
you're in control of your life.
There's good power,
good energy that you're in.
Good.
Uh,
like you're in a good energy in your
life.
And it was pretty sweet.
Well,
you can
definitely adjust the way you approach
certain situations,
right?
You could look at things in a positive
way or we all know people that look at
things like,
oh,
the world fucking closing in on me,
and you're like,
whoa,
whoa.
You live in America.
You're not in Ethiopia.
You have both your feet.
You're not paralyzed.
You don't have malaria.
What the fuck are you complaining about?
Exactly like it's,
it's,
it's a perspective issue with a lot of
people,
but the way you approach different
scenarios in your life has a huge impact
on how you feel and as an athlete
especially I would imagine as a fighter,
it's very important to maintain a
healthy mindset and to keep your stress
levels at a very low level while you're
training and while you're going through
camp and like the law,
like we've all seen fighters that go
through camps and they have fucking
crazy relationship problems at the same
time and it fucks them up,
man.
Right?
Laughing,
right?
Yeah.
No,
I mean doing my,
my like I get hungry and I'm getting
angry.
You know,
my girls just say,
all right,
you gotta stay away from him.
Let's get him some food.
But that's reasonable,
right?
And that's just crankiness from cutting
weight,
but like crazy people in your life,
like if you date and some crazy girl,
if you're a girl and you're dating a
crazy guy and they cry like a lot of
people,
if they're not getting enough attention
from you,
they start drama because issues like if
you're focusing too much on other
things,
they get upset at.
You cut those people along awful long
time ago,
Joe.
Yep.
Very important,
right?
Yeah.
Hey,
I gotta ask you,
man,
what,
what do you think about.
We think about God.
What is your theory on that?
You believe,
believe in God.
Do you know him?
No,
I don't.
I don't know.
Maybe omnipresent in everything I am.
I definitely am open to all sorts of
possibilities.
Post life.
I don't that I have any sort of lock on
what happens that I haven't experienced.
So for me to say that there's no god or
that there isn't some omnipresent entity
or or energy or something that is the
guiding force of the universe,
that would be ridiculous.
What do I know?
I mean,
I think human beings,
we are in some sort of strange state of
development where we're aware of our own
existence.
We're aware of life,
we're aware of certain rules of the
universe seems to follow,
or the universe seems to be,
if everything seems to be constantly in
motion and changing,
know whether it is,
uh,
the,
the orbit of planets,
whether it is the biological life on
planets,
whether it's the life of stars,
things have a life.
And they,
they come and they go,
and then even you,
the galaxies themselves,
every galaxy in the center of every
galaxy has a supermassive black hole
that's one half of one percent of the
entire mass of the galaxy.
And that supermassive black hole is
sucking that galaxy into it's fucking
center into the event horizon.
When you see these spiral galaxies at
the center of those spiral galaxies is a
black hole that's absorbing all the
matter slowly but surely of that galaxy.
And then no one knows what is going on
in that black hole.
They don't,
they don't understand what it is.
They have theories,
but one of the theories of black holes
is that inside every black hole is
potentially a whole nother universe,
so there's hundreds of billions of
galaxies.
Each galaxy has a super massive black
hole in the center of it,
and inside each one of those galaxies
may be hundreds of millions of other
galaxies,
hundreds of millions of other
universities,
so the the idea that anybody could sit
here and tell you there's no god,
man of God.
I think it's incredibly arrogant when
people say there is no god.
What I think is that religion clearly
shows the hand of man.
It clearly shows the manipulation of
other human beings where they have taken
some universal rules are there are some,
some universal golden rule is treat
others the way you would like to be
treated and understanding that loving
each other.
Brothers and sisters and friends and
community has massive benefits and you
feel connected to each other and it is
the right way to be.
It's there's,
there's a benefit to that.
We all feel it.
We know it.
The love that you have for your
children,
like I know the love that I have for my
children and the love that I have for my
wife or my friends or people that are
close to me when I see there's.
There's,
there's a beauty in that that is it's
magical and I don't know if that beauty
and that magic is to in its to enforce a
sense of community so that we can
continue to breed so that we were
rewarded a,
these natural reward systems so that we
can continue to foster life and that we
can continue to evolve and grow.
I don't know.
I don't know what it is,
but I know that the best things in life
are they're connected to love and I
would think that if there's any guiding
force,
any beautiful force of the universe,
it is that love and even the love of the
beauty of the universe itself.
There's a love that I get when I last
night went out on my porch and I smoked
a little tube and I looked up at the
stars and I was.
I fell in love with the stars.
Man.
I feel love when I look out into the
universe.
I mean,
I think I was one of my favorite things
to do is look at stars.
Just look up and go fuck big.
Same Way I do my.
That's funny.
I'm always looking at the moon like,
man,
it's full moon and the stars in the sky,
one quarter the size of the earth and
it's just floating up there.
Especially when you're out in the middle
of nowhere.
Like it sounded.
Look up,
Mrs. Pure dark man.
Look at that dude,
man,
that's sick.
When I was a kid I went,
um,
I was in camp once.
A boy scout camp in New Hampshire.
Boston.
Yeah.
I used to for a little while to these
fucking kids.
I went to boy scout camp with criminals.
Man,
he's fucking kids.
I was A.
I lived in Jamaica plain,
which is kind of a sketchy.
It's gentrified now,
but in the 19,
late 19 seventies it was kind of
sketchy.
Where's it at?
Jamaica plains is a suburb of Boston.
Oh,
Boston.
And it was a,
it was just not a good neighborhood.
We didn't have any money,
but the kids that I went to,
boy scout camp with,
they would like take other kids and
fucking tie him up and leave him in the
woods and shed.
It was like,
it was so sketchy,
but they gave us rifles to man.
We have 20 twos and bows and arrows,
so we're out there and it was not that
organized.
It was weird because I remember I was
out there,
we were doing something and I heard,
I go,
what is that?
And the guy goes,
I was a ricochet.
I go ricochet.
Like as in a bullet,
I guess someone hit a rock and it
ricocheted.
I'm like,
I'm out.
fuck this.
Just from the rest of the time I was
there for two weeks,
I'll just went fishing.
I just abandoned everybody went fishing.
I didn't even know I was gone.
Like I could've drowned out there.
No one cared.
But I remember going outside and for the
first time in my life being in a place
where there was no lights,
there was no city,
there was nothing.
We were just in the woods and you look
up and just be like,
fuck.
Yeah,
like look at all those stars.
Those are out there all the time.
I don't see them all the time.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
kids these days probably don't even see
them at all.
IPADS,
everything that's going on.
Have you been to.
I know they don't even bother.
Have you been to the Big Island?
Nope.
Dude,
there's,
um,
there's an observatory at the top of a
model isn't Maunaloa the,
um,
the Keck observatory in the big island
and the way the big island is set up,
they have special diffused lighting so
that the street lights don't provide
light pollution.
So you could see everything and you go
through the clouds and dude,
it looks like that when you,
when you're up there,
I think it's like,
I want to say like 13,000 feet above sea
level.
But when you look up at the sky dude,
you see the Milky Way,
like the full Milky Way.
It's incredible.
Like see if you find it,
just go do google images of from the
Keck observatory because maybe that's a
good one.
Yeah,
that's what exactly what it looks like.
Dude.
You sit up there and you look up and you
like,
like if you're going to go there,
you've got to go when it's no moon,
because I went the last time I went,
we fucked up and it was a full moon.
It was still beautiful,
but it was a full moon and you just
don't see as many stars.
Yeah.
If you can get up there and you don't
have to go to the very top you go to.
There's like a visitor center.
That's all you need to do.
They have some telescopes,
but you don't even want to look at the
telescope.
Just look up man,
look up and enjoy.
It's amazing.
It's.
I really feel like there's something
going on with people today.
One of the things with the arrogance of
human beings and the ridiculous way we
behave,
I think part of it is connected to the
fact that we don't see space anymore.
I think space is so humbling and it,
I think it's psychedelic when I don't
even have to do.
I don't have to smoke pot and have to do
anything.
When I go to Hawaii and I look up,
I get high.
I feel like I just like,
it puts me in perspective.
It lets me know like you're in a magical
place.
You're on this,
this strange circular spaceship that's
hurling through infinity and above you
is an infinite number of giant
explosions,
huge fireballs in the sky.
We have floating there.
No one knows why.
So that's what I think about God,
that,
that is,
you know,
I just think a lot of people,
they use religion and God as a
scaffolding to try to be a good person
and to try to have rules and to try to
have structure in their life and to try
to give themselves something to look
forward to,
which I think is a good thing.
I think there's a lot of good things
that religion provides people,
but I also think it provides people with
a lot of excuses to be shitty to people.
A lot of hate,
you know,
a lot of,
I mean especially ancient religions that
suppress women or suppress gay people or
suppress people's rights in any way,
shape or form based on this idea that,
you know,
it's ancient scripture tells them
they're not supposed to do certain
things.
Yeah,
I think that's all ridiculous,
but I think that's not really God.
That's the hand of man.
So if it's the.
The problem with even the term God is
that it's Kinda been co opted by
religion,
which has definitely been co opted by,
man.
You learn.
You can learn a lot from ancient
religious texts and ancient knowledge
that people knew.
They figured things out a long time ago
and they were trying to figure out a way
to pass that down onto other people.
But the problem is in the translation,
like none of the ancient religions were
ever written in English.
None of them know they were written all
sorts of different.
Like the Bible for here is a perfect
example of the original Bible was
written in ancient Hebrew.
Well actually Aramaic,
if you go to the Dead Sea scrolls were
in Aramaic and the Dead Sea scrolls
contain a lot of the stories that are in
the ancient bibles and it's like it's
really convoluted.
The translation between Aramaic to Latin
or Greek to back to English.
It's like you lose a lot and then an
ancient Hebrew and in ancient Hebrew
also words double is numbers,
letters double his numbers.
There's no numbers in ancient Hebrew.
So like the letter a is also the number
one.
Yup.
So words also have numerical value,
like the word God and the word love.
They have the same numerical value
because the numbers in the letters like
what it means something.
It's not like you can say,
oh go fuck yourself.
Like it's not,
it's not like just a phonetic language.
It's a language that also has
mathematics incorporated to it and that
meant something.
It was a part of.
So when you take these ancient Hebrew
sentences and you translate them to
English and you don't just translate it
to English and translate them to Latin,
he translate them to Greek and then you
translate into English a lot lost in the
process,
but I think these people were trying to
figure some things out about life and I
think we could probably learn something
from them,
but for sure a lot of it was people
manipulating the other people around
them and saying,
God says this,
you have to do that or,
or you will die in a fiery fucking pit
in the middle of the earth and oral just
to the teacher.
So there was a lot of horseshit involved
in religion.
So it's not,
it's not all bad.
It's not all good.
But it's interesting.
Yeah.
Yin and Yang.
There's a lot going on,
Jeremy.
There is.
Do you live right?
Yeah.
Right.
So back to you and your career,
um,
because we're going to wrap this up soon
and we go to restaurant for 20 hollow
for 20.
For all you people out there.
If you're,
um,
if you're looking at your career right
now and looking at your future,
you're trying to just get a big fight
right now.
So you're,
you're calling these guys have a set
anything up if they.
No,
man,
I,
uh,
like I said,
man,
I,
I hassle Sean Shelby Dude.
And I'm like,
Yo dude.
He just like,
what does he say?
He's just,
you know,
he just kinda looks like,
man,
this guy's crazy.
He's like,
he's always had.
I'll get you something,
I'll get you some.
But the division is kind of in a funk
right now.
Either everybody's got fights or I've
already fought people or you know,
they're coming off losses normally.
Like they try to prepare you with the
wind.
So I told Shawn,
I go,
hey man,
if I ain't going to get like a frankie
or an Aldo fight,
I'm like,
give me somebody outside real quick.
Let me,
let me just go get a good wind.
And like you said,
I'm still right there in the mix.
So then when it all pans out,
I'm right there
big though.
Here's my question.
Like if,
let's say there's a big title fight
coming up,
say if,
uh,
although who just won the interim title
is going to defend his title against
someone else in the top 10 and you know,
you see that coming up to you and you
don't have a fight scheduled.
Do you start thinking
baby,
someone can get injured and you might
get that call because mma,
particularly the UFC is notorious for
last minute fallouts or guys get
injured.
Uh,
right after my fight was a right before
UFC 200.
So I,
right as I got done,
you know,
I was 100 percent healthy.
He had no injuries.
I was like,
Hey,
you know,
I was like,
ah,
I just want to let you know,
you know,
I know maybe some people were ahead of
me,
but I'll let you know I'm going to be
ready in 100 percent focused.
And uh,
you know,
I didn't do anything.
I went out and joined myself one time
and then I was,
I was training,
I was back to doing sprints strike right
away.
And then about two weeks before that
fighter.
So I ended up going to Mexico on
vacation,
my cousin got married and then I just
went out and enjoyed myself.
But for like two weeks straight I was
continuing to stay on point.
Yeah,
I stayed on just in case.
Yeah.
Because things happen,
you know,
and I can be that guy to step up and I
let them know and I let it.
I let everybody else know that,
hey,
I'm,
I'm ready,
I'm ready to take that next step and you
can rely on me.
And it's tricky though because you're so
big,
you know,
if like if something was scheduled for
two weeks from now and then all the
sudden you got this call,
you really can't make weight in two
weeks.
No,
not now.
Yeah.
Now.
So,
you know,
like I said,
I was,
I was preparing for $200 and it didn't
happen.
So now I've,
I've,
I've taken my time off,
I've enjoyed myself.
I've traveled and uh,
you know,
I enjoyed yourself,
but you're not fat.
This is where it's so confusing.
Like I'm looking at you right now.
You're fucking in shape.
Your fit dude.
I just ran the other day and I am in
shape.
It's just I,
I,
my coach,
he just,
we just,
I stay on my diet.
I've been enjoying myself like on the
weekends and I love lava cakes and ice
cream and a who doesn't,
hey,
you know,
and I,
I,
you know,
I have to enjoy myself a little bit
because there's got to be a Yin and
Yang.
There's got to be a dark side and then
there's got to be the good side.
It as of right now,
I've been back on the Diet and
everything is going good.
I've been,
I've been doing my runs.
I just really haven't been that dialed
in.
Like,
Hey,
I have a set date and I'm doing things
in particular as I was training right
after my fight I was ready and set and
still striving toward that goal.
It just didn't happen that way.
That's fine,
but give me a fight.
I need Sean Shelby,
do you get me a fight night?
I want those exciting fights.
I think a lot of people want to see me
and Josie auto get after it.
They want to see me and conor mcgregor.
He's a heavy handed guy.
He's an exciting guy.
He's an interesting dude and people want
to see the one test that they want to
see the live fights.
They don't want to see the,
the,
the land pregnant.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
You gotta win.
I understand that people got to provide
for their family,
but I like to personally get into legit
fistfights to where I liked to scrap it.
No matter where the fight goes.
If you take me down,
I'm trying to elbow you in the head.
I'm trying to get back up.
I'm trying to put you to sleep.
So I,
um,
I feel like I'm an exciting fighter.
I've been in the game a long time.
I'm,
I'm ready for that next level of
competition and just staying focused and
dialed in.
You're definitely a fan favorite.
And your favorite of mine,
man.
I'm a big fan.
I love sign the shorts for you by the
way.
I want to see him in that new new,
uh,
building.
Man.
I hope you get that.
Well,
we fucked up man.
We were in the process of buying a
building and it looks like it fell
through somehow,
or another guy that
owns a building such a Twat Burger.
I don't know what,
but we'll figure it out,
but if it gets something when we do get
it,
what we're going to do is we're gonna
set up a gallery and I definitely,
I got Jeremy Stevens shorts and hand
wraps from his last fight.
We'll put those in a frame and uh,
we'll get you to sign that and put that
up.
Hell yeah,
appreciate it.
Me,
I've always been a fan too and I know
you always represented me very well and
I've watched that podcast that you're
doing it.
I just thought that was awesome.
You know,
in La,
a lot of people like,
hey man,
Joe Rogan gives you a lot of love and
all.
I kept my shorts and I was like,
man,
I gotta get back on the podcast.
And I was like,
you know what?
This guy actually offered me some money
and I was going to sell them.
And I was like,
Nah man,
I got to give them to my man.
Joe,
oh,
thank you
brother.
I appreciate that.
Very much.
Appreciate having me on here too.
All right.
You could find Jeremy on twitter.
Lill he then mma.
I'm instagram yet,
but is he than MMA?
All right man.
Look forward to seeing you soon,
brother.
Hey,
thank you guys.
Folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with Justin Wren.
Fight for the forgotten building wells
in the Congo.
Bitch.